Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, add free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to the rest ishistory.com and join the club. That is the rest is history.com. This episode is brought to you by SAP. With investors, customers, and workers demanding more from your business,
感谢收听《历史的余味》（The Rest is History）。如需收听每周的加更节目、享受无广告体验、抢先收听系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。本期节目由 SAP 赞助播出。随着投资者、客户和员工对您的业务提出更高要求，
it's time to try SAP. Its AI-powered capabilities can help you streamline costs, Connect with new suppliers and manage payroll even when your business is being pulled in different directions. To deliver a quality product at a fair price, while paying your people what they're worth too, so your business can stay unfazed. Learn more at SAP.com slash uncertainty. A week or two ago, I fell into conversation with a constituent. the middle-aged, quite ordinary working man. After a sentence or two about the weather,
是时候尝试 SAP 了。其人工智能驱动的功能可以帮助您精简成本、对接新供应商并管理工资发放，即使在您的业务面临多方压力时也能应对自如。在以合理价格提供优质产品的同时，也能给予员工应得的报酬，让您的业务从容不迫。详情请访问 SAP.com/uncertainty。一两周前，我和一位选民交谈，他是一位中年、非常普通的工薪阶层。在聊了几句天气之后，
he suddenly said, If I had the money to go, I wouldn't stay in this country. I have three children. I shall be satisfied till I have seen them all settled overseas. In this country, in 15 or 20 years' time, the black man will have the whip hand over the white man. I can already hear the chorus of execration. How dare I say such a horrible thing?
他突然说：“如果我有钱离开，我就不会留在这个国家。我有三个孩子。直到看到他们都在海外安顿下来，我才会感到满足。在这个国家，15 或 20 年后，黑人将凌驾于白人之上。” 我已经能听到一片谴责之声了。我怎么敢说出如此可怕的话？
I dare I stir up trouble and inflame feelings by repeating such a conversation. The answer is that I do not have the right not to do so. Here is a decent ordinary fellow Englishman, who in broad daylight in my own town says to me, is a member of parliament, that this country will not be worth living in for his children. I simply do not have the right to shrug my shoulders and think about something else.
我怎么敢通过重复这样的谈话来挑起事端、煽动情绪？答案是，我没有权利不这样做。这是一个体面、普通的英国同胞，他在光天化日之下，在我自己的城镇里对我说——作为一名国会议员——这个国家对他孩子来说已经不值得居住了。我根本没有权利耸耸肩，去想别的事情。
What he is saying, thousands and hundreds of thousands are saying and thinking in the areas that are already undergoing the total transformation to which there is no parallel in a thousand years of English history so the unmistakable tones there of John Enoch Powell who was MP for Wolverhampton southwest and he is beginning what is perhaps I in fact I would say certainly the single most incendiary speech in British political history and he was speaking on the 20th of April in 1968 to
他所说的，成千上万的人在那些已经经历着彻底变革的地区也在说着、想着，这种变革在千年英国历史上是绝无仅有的。所以，刚才那段话有着约翰·伊诺克·鲍威尔（John Enoch Powell）那不可错认的语调，他当时是伍尔弗汉普顿西南选区的议员。他正在发表的，或许我应该说，绝对是英国政治史上最具煽动性的一次演讲。他是在 1968 年 4 月 20 日，向
conservative activists at the Midland Hotel in Birmingham and his subject was of course as you could tell from that extract the ever sensitive topic of immigration and the speech became associated with one phrase
伯明翰米德兰酒店的保守党活动人士发表讲话，而他的主题，正如你们从那段摘录中听到的那样，是移民这个极其敏感的话题。这次演讲最终与一个短语联系在了一起，
above all. It was a quotation from Virgil's great epic poem The Aeneid spoken by the Sybil. And the Sybil said in Powell's translation of it, like the Roman, I seem to see the River Tyber foaming with much blood. And so Dominic, that speech ever since has been remembered as the Rivers of Blood speech. Yes, and although it may not mean much to our overseas listeners, to anybody in Britain, it will be very, very well known, even to people who are perhaps not
最重要的是，它引用了维吉尔伟大史诗《埃涅阿斯纪》中西比尔（Sybil）所说的话。西比尔在鲍威尔的翻译中说道：“就像罗马人一样，我似乎看到台伯河泛着大量的鲜血。” 所以，多米尼克，从那时起，那次演讲就被称为“血河”演讲。是的，虽然这对我们的海外听众来说可能意义不大，但对于英国的任何人来说，它都非常、非常出名，即使是那些可能对
massively familiar with the details of Powell's career that have heard of his name and they'll heard the phrase, Rivers of Blood. And actually this speech made Enoch Powell a household name in Britain for the next 25 years. So he was the kind of politician. He was the kind of public figure. I think that almost everybody had heard of. His name became a shorthand for the issue and for a particular kind of politics. And his name Enoch is so striking, isn't it? So it became a kind of shorthand. Exactly. To a lot of people, he was the walking embodiment of nativism and nationalism, English nationalism, I suppose. And a lot of people, and including many of our listeners, would probably go further than that,
鲍威尔职业生涯细节不太了解的人，也听说过他的名字，听过“血河”这个短语。事实上，这次演讲让伊诺克·鲍威尔在接下来的 25 年里成为了英国的家喻户晓的名字。他就是那种政治家，那种公众人物。我想几乎每个人都听说过他。他的名字成了这个议题和某种特定政治风格的代名词。他的名字“伊诺克”非常引人注目，不是吗？所以它变成了一种简写。没错。对很多人来说，他是本土主义和民族主义——我想是英国民族主义——的活化身。而很多人，包括我们的许多听众，可能会更进一步，
and they'd say he was an out-and-out racist. And then on the other hand, there'll be some of our listeners who say, no, not at all. He was the one man who dared to say the unsayable. He was a prophet. He was a man who sacrificed his political career for his principles. So I think you can argue that his influence is far greater than that, and many people who actually became prime minister. You know, Enot Powell's name is remembered today in a way that, frankly, Harold Wilson's or even Jim Callahan's, Tom, are not.
他们会说他是一个彻头彻尾的种族主义者。而另一方面，也会有一些听众说，不，完全不是。他是唯一一个敢于说出不可言说之事的人。他是一位先知。他是一个为了原则而牺牲自己政治生涯的人。所以我认为你可以说，他的影响力远比许多真正当上首相的人要大。你知道，伊诺克·鲍威尔的名字今天被人们记住的方式，坦率地说，哈罗德·威尔逊（Harold Wilson）甚至吉姆·卡拉汉（Jim Callaghan）的名字都没有达到。
I mean, he's remembered overwhelmingly today for the River's blood speech. But, Dominic, he was also, I mean, a huge influence on Mrs. Thatcher's economic policy. And also, he was virulently opposed to the common market, which became the European Union. So in a sense, also he was the kind of the godfather of Brexit. He completely was. I think so many of the arguments that Brexiteers make when they're sort of more cerebral arguments. can be traced back to Powell. Even today, to liberals, his name is short-hand for kind of what they see is the ugliness
我的意思是，今天人们记住他主要是因为“血河”演讲。但是，多米尼克，他同时也是撒切尔夫人经济政策的巨大影响者。而且，他强烈反对共同市场，也就是后来的欧盟。所以从某种意义上说，他也是英国脱欧的教父。他完全是。我认为脱欧派在进行更理性的辩论时所使用的许多论点，都可以追溯到鲍威尔。即使在今天，对于自由派来说，他的名字也是他们所认为的丑陋的
of populism. And to his admirers, he is the ultimate example of a politician who dared to say what he believed, even though he knew he'd be pillared for it. So it's a fair guess that those of our listeners who vote liberal, Democrat or Labour, think Powell as awful, the devil incarnate, and those who vote conservative, or if we have reform voting listeners, they would see him very much as a hero. I'm not sure about conservatives. Well, conservatives are divided.
民粹主义的代名词。而对于他的崇拜者来说，他是那种敢于说出自己信仰的政治家的终极典范，尽管他知道自己会因此受到抨击。所以可以肯定地说，我们那些投票给自由民主党或工党的听众认为鲍威尔很糟糕，是恶魔的化身；而那些投票给保守党，或者如果我们有支持改革党的听众，他们会把他视为英雄。我不确定保守党人怎么看。嗯，保守党人是有分歧的。
I think so, well, there are only about three conservatives left, aren't there? That's true. But I mean, certainly the conservative leadership has always been very anxious to distinguish itself from Enoch Powell. You're right about that. And actually, there is an argument which will perhaps come to later in the program, that one of the effects of Powell's speech, unexpectedly and perhaps inadvertently, is that actually muffles the political debate at Westminster to some degree
我想是的，嗯，现在只剩下大约三个保守党人了，不是吗？那是真的。但我的意思是，当然，保守党领导层一直非常急于将自己与伊诺克·鲍威尔区分开来。你说得对。事实上，有一个观点，我们稍后可能会在节目中讨论，那就是鲍威尔演讲的影响之一，出乎意料且可能是无意地，实际上在某种程度上压制了威斯敏斯特的政治辩论，
because politicians are nervous about following in its footsteps. Now, I thought it would be good to do this. It's a history podcast. I'm not going to preach to the listeners about what to think. It's so controversial. The issues are still so raw that I think it's good for listeners to make up their own minds. And because we are a history podcast, we should begin with the historical figure. So there's a great book on Enot Powell, like the Roman, by Simon Heifer.
因为政客们害怕重蹈覆辙。现在，我觉得做这个节目很好。这是一个历史播客。我不会向听众灌输该怎么想。这太有争议了。这些问题仍然如此尖锐，我认为让听众自己做出判断是件好事。而且因为我们是一个历史播客，我们应该从这位历史人物开始。西蒙·海弗（Simon Heffer）写了一本关于伊诺克·鲍威尔的伟大的书，叫《像罗马人一样》（Like the Roman）。
Now, Simon Heffer is himself a man of very robust opinions, but his book is really, really, it's great. I mean, I shouldn't say but, as though there's a contradiction. And his book is really, really good. It's really, he really gets under Powell's skin. And Powell is a pretty strange character, I think, Tom, wouldn't you agree? I mean, he's a very, very, he's an eccentric figure. Yes. He's fantastically strange.
西蒙·海弗本人也是一个观点非常强硬的人，但他的书真的、真的非常棒。我的意思是，我不应该说“但是”，好像这有什么矛盾似的。他的书真的非常好。他真的深入到了鲍威尔的内心。鲍威尔是一个相当奇怪的人物，我想，汤姆，你同意吗？我的意思是，他是一个非常、非常古怪的人物。是的。他非常奇怪。
He is. So he's born in, we have a lot of Birmingham people on this show. He was born in Birmingham in 1912, so he's 20 years behind another Brummy, very intense, very romantic kind of man, J.R. Tolkien. And indeed, they went to the same school. So Powell is an only child. His father was a primary school headmaster. He's an incredibly precocious little boy. So he's called the, his parents call him the professor. Do you know what he was called at school? What was he called at school? Scowly-Powley. Yeah, because he's, he very rarely smiles, or at least never smiles in public. So when he would, do you see this?
他确实是。他出生于——我们节目中有很多伯明翰人——他于 1912 年出生在伯明翰，所以他比另一位伯明翰人、非常强烈、非常浪漫的男人 J.R.R. 托尔金晚了 20 年。事实上，他们上了同一所学校。鲍威尔是独生子。他的父亲是一位小学校长。他是一个早熟得令人难以置信的小男孩。所以他被称为——他的父母叫他“教授”。你知道他在学校里被叫什么吗？他在学校里被叫什么？“斯考利-波利”（Scowly-Powley）。是的，因为他很少笑，或者至少在公共场合从不笑。所以当他……你明白吗？
when he was six on Sundays, he would make his parents sort of assemble, and then he would give them a lecture about the books that he'd read that week. And then when he goes to school, everybody says he's a really unfriendly, austere boy. He walks around, he's got this piercing cold blue eyes. He's always on his own. He's always carrying this gigantic pile of books. But Tom, if the parallels are not striking enough already, he's also very keen on the classics, isn't he? Well, and particularly Herodotus. So he begins translating Herodotus when he's 14. How old were you when you started, Horotus? Oh, much, much, much later. But one of the reasons, so he's called John, but he changes his name, his second name is Enoch, and he starts
当他六岁的时候，在星期天，他会让他父母集合起来，然后他会给他们讲关于他那周读的书的讲座。然后当他上学时，每个人都说他是一个非常不友好、严厉的男孩。他走来走去，有着一双锐利、冰冷的蓝眼睛。他总是独来独往。他总是带着一大堆书。但是汤姆，如果这些相似之处还不够惊人的话，他也非常热衷于古典学，不是吗？嗯，特别是希罗多德。所以他在 14 岁时就开始翻译希罗多德了。你开始读希罗多德的时候多大？哦，晚得多，晚得多。但其中一个原因——他叫约翰，但他改了名字，他的中间名是伊诺克，他开始
using Enoch as his first name because there is a classicist who's done a translation of Thucydides called John Powell, and the young Enoch Powell is already looking ahead and thinking, well, I don't want to be muddled with him. I mean, that's a strange thing to be thinking when you're eight or whatever it is. So he was so clever that he started the sixth form at King Edwards, Birmingham, two years early, by which point he was already reading Goethe and Nietzsche in German. I don't think they even did German at school. It was just learning in his spare time.
使用伊诺克作为他的名字，因为有一位古典学者翻译了修昔底德，名叫约翰·鲍威尔，年轻的伊诺克·鲍威尔已经在向前看，心想，嗯，我不想和那个人混淆。我的意思是，当你八岁或者无论多大时，这真是一个奇怪的想法。所以他太聪明了，以至于他提前两年开始了伯明翰爱德华国王学校的六年级学习，那时他已经在用德语阅读歌德和尼采了。我不认为他们学校甚至教德语。这只是他在业余时间学习的。
So very Tolkien-like, actually, learning all these languages. And then he wins a scholarship to Trinity College, Cambridge. And there, if you read the accounts of him at Trinity College, Cambridge, they are hilarious. So he would get up every day, start work at 5 o'clock in the morning. Again, like you, he would work until 9 o'clock at night. He turned down every social invitation, including an invitation from the master of the college and his wife to dinner. Because he said, I'm so sorry, I've got massive work pressure. I can't do anything.
所以真的很像托尔金，实际上，学习所有这些语言。然后他赢得了剑桥大学三一学院的奖学金。在那里，如果你读到关于他在剑桥大学三一学院的记录，它们非常滑稽。他每天起床，早上 5 点就开始工作。和你一样，他会一直工作到晚上 9 点。他拒绝了所有的社交邀请，包括学院院长和院长夫人邀请他共进晚餐。因为他说，我很抱歉，我有巨大的工作压力。我什么都做不了。
So he never did anything but work. But he won all these prizes. And just to say on the prizes, he enters every prize that is open to a Classics undergraduate in his first year. And he wins every single one. and that is a feat that's never been achieved before or since. So, I mean, he is an astonishingly brilliant man. I mean, there's no doubt about that. You know, whatever you think of as politics, there's no denigrating his intellectual
所以他除了工作什么都不做。但他赢得了所有这些奖项。顺便说一下奖项，他在第一年参加了所有向古典学本科生开放的奖项竞赛。他赢得了每一个奖项。这是一个前无古人、后无来者的壮举。所以，我的意思是，他是一个令人震惊的聪明人。我的意思是，这一点毫无疑问。你知道，无论你怎么看他的政治，都无法贬低他的智力
sort of calibre. He became a fellow. He started work on a herodotus lexicon, which I have. You have that? Is it good? Yeah. I mean, it's very useful. I used it when I did my translation.
水平。他成为了一名研究员。他开始编写一本希罗多德词典，我有一本。你有那本？它好用吗？是的。我的意思是，它非常有用。我在做翻译时用过它。
He worked on Thucydides as well, didn't he? He started working in a revised edition of Thucydides. and he's also writing these sort of very deeply wrought poems under the influence of A.E. Houseman. So he's a massive, massive Houseman. Yes, and like Houseman, he has kind of unrequited crushes on beautiful young men, doesn't he? And writes lots of poetry about it. Yeah, I think at this stage, he's, I mean, insofar as he's a sexual creature at all, he's gay. You know, his passions all lie in that direction.
他也研究修昔底德，不是吗？他开始编写修昔底德的修订版。而且他还在 A.E. 豪斯曼（A.E. Housman）的影响下写这些非常深刻的诗歌。所以他是一个巨大的、巨大的豪斯曼迷。是的，像豪斯曼一样，他有一种对美丽的年轻男子的单相思，不是吗？并写了很多关于此的诗。是的，我想在这个阶段，他——我的意思是，就他是一个性生物而言，他是同性恋。你知道，他的激情都指向那个方向。
What's still alive at 22? what is it, a clean up standing lad like you, all that kind of thing. That's his vibe. Exactly. All that stuff. And he actually writes to his parents at one point. He says, I have absolutely no interest in women at all. So, you know, there's no doubt what's...
22岁时还活着吗？那是什么，一个像你这样干净利落的小伙子，所有那类事情。那是他的氛围。没错。所有那些东西。他实际上在某个时候写信给他的父母。他说，我对女性完全没有兴趣。所以，你知道，毫无疑问是什么……
I mean, he does actually later on get married and has children. So he has three slightly contradictory ambitions. First of all, he's obsessed with Nietzsche. Nietzsche was a professor at the age of 24, and Powell wants to beat him. And he fails by not by much. So at 25, he has made professor of Greek at the University of Sydney. So this is in 1937. At this point, he's the youngest professor in the British Empire.
我的意思是，他后来确实结婚并有了孩子。所以他有三个略有矛盾的抱负。首先，他痴迷于尼采。尼采在 24 岁时就成了教授，鲍威尔想打败他。他失败了，但差距不大。所以 25 岁时，他被任命为悉尼大学的希腊语教授。这是在 1937 年。此时，他是大英帝国最年轻的教授。
Number two, talking to the British Empire, he wants to be viceroy of India. And actually, again, in this slightly eccentric way, since he was a student, he's been teaching himself Urdu so that he can communicate with his future subjects. And actually, when he becomes MP for Wolverhampton, he would talk to some of his constituents and keep notes on them in Urdu. on his Indian constituents. One other thing he wanted to do, which I learned from listening to his desert island discs with Sue Lawley, is that he apparently wanted to become a musician. And unsurprisingly, with his nationalism and his love of German, he's obsessed by Wagner. So four of his eight discs are from Wagner, one from each of the operas in the ring cycle.
第二，谈到大英帝国，他想成为印度总督。而且实际上，以这种略显古怪的方式，自从他还是学生时起，他就一直在自学乌尔都语，以便与他未来的臣民交流。事实上，当他成为伍尔弗汉普顿的议员时，他会与他的一些选民交谈，并用乌尔都语记录关于他们的笔记。关于他的印度选民。他想做的另一件事，我是从听苏·劳利（Sue Lawley）主持的《荒岛唱片》（Desert Island Discs）中得知的，是他显然想成为一名音乐家。不出所料，凭借他的民族主义和对德语的热爱，他痴迷于瓦格纳。所以他的八张唱片中有四张来自瓦格纳，每张来自《指环》系列歌剧中的一部。
And one of them is a bit of Wagner that I sang on the stage of the Royal Albert Hall. Do you know, the parallels are so, so striking. it's really, really chilling, actually. Well, all of this, I mean, the Wagner thing is interesting because I think it expresses something very important about Powell that's often missed. Powell appears to be a very austere, chilly man, but I think deep down, he's basically a 19th century
其中一张是我在皇家阿尔伯特音乐厅舞台上唱过的瓦格纳片段。你知道，这些相似之处太、太惊人了。实际上真的很令人不寒而栗。嗯，所有这些，我的意思是，瓦格纳的事情很有趣，因为我认为它表达了关于鲍威尔的一个经常被忽略的重要方面。鲍威尔看起来是一个非常严厉、冷漠的人，但我认为在内心深处，他基本上是一个 19 世纪的
German, capital R, romantic nationalist. Do you not think? I mean, the Wagner, the Nietzsche, all of that. So he's a man out of time. When you hear him on Desdandes talking about each of the Wagner extracts, I mean, he's choking back tears. He's astonishingly romantic with the capital R. I think he's the classic example which you sometimes get of this kind of incredibly bright only child who just from the moment he can walk and talk is like somebody from a different century and completely inhabits that persona and just seems completely adrift in the modern world.
德国大写 R 的浪漫民族主义者。你不觉得吗？我的意思是，瓦格纳、尼采，所有这些。所以他是一个不合时宜的人。当你听到他在《荒岛唱片》中谈论每一段瓦格纳片段时，我的意思是，他在强忍泪水。他是一个大写 R 的惊人浪漫主义者。我认为他是那种你有时会遇到的经典例子，这种极其聪明的独生子，从他能走路和说话的那一刻起，就像一个来自不同世纪的人，完全沉浸在那种人格中，似乎完全迷失在现代世界中。
Anyway, well, actually, I'm being being a bit harsh, because when the war breaks out in 1939, he immediately leaves Sydney and he comes back to England, he's determined, he's been, you know, he's very anti-appeasement, he saw the war coming, he always said he would join up straight away, he becomes a private and the Royal Warwickshers, and then he rises really rapidly, I mean, he has a really good war. He goes to North Africa, he becomes a major, then a colonel, he works on the logistics for El Alamein, he goes into military intelligence, he's sent to Delhi. By the end of the war, his deputy, director of intelligence in Delhi, and he is one of the youngest brigadiers in the British Empire. His big regret, I don't know if he talked about this with Sue Lawley on Desert Island Discs, he is gutted that he hasn't been killed. So he never saw combat. And when he was asked, how would you like to be remembered? He said, I should like to have been killed in the war. I think that's on Desiland Discs. It's in the context of the person that he's written his love poetry to.
总之，嗯，实际上，我有点苛刻了，因为当 1939 年战争爆发时，他立即离开悉尼回到英国，他下定决心，他一直，你知道，他非常反对绥靖政策，他预见到了战争，他总是说他会立即参军，他成为了一名皇家沃里克郡团的列兵，然后他迅速晋升，我的意思是，他经历了一场非常好的战争。他去了北非，成为了一名少校，然后是上校，他负责阿拉曼战役的后勤工作，他进入了军事情报部门，他被派往德里。到战争结束时，他是德里情报部门的副主任，他是大英帝国最年轻的准将之一。他最大的遗憾，我不知道他是否在《荒岛唱片》中与苏·劳利谈过这个，他非常懊恼自己没有被杀。所以他从未见过战斗。当被问及，你希望人们如何记住你？他说，我希望在战争中阵亡。我想那是在《荒岛唱片》里。这是在他写情诗的对象背景下。
and Sue Lawley presses him about who this person is and he says, I'm not going to say. But I think we know who it is. It was a kind of young undergraduate called AWJ Thomas, who died during the fall of Singapore. And I think his statement about he wished he died in the war is kind of tied up with that. I mean, very, very deep waters, very housemanian waters. Very, yes. Anyway, he comes back to England and he's decided by now he wants to make his name in politics. Remember, he wants to be viceroy of India.
苏·劳利追问这个人是谁，他说，我不会说。但我认为我们知道是谁。那是一个叫 A.W.J. 托马斯的年轻本科生，他在新加坡陷落期间去世了。我认为他关于希望在战争中阵亡的声明与此有关。我的意思是，非常、非常深的水，非常豪斯曼式的水。非常，是的。总之，他回到英国，决定现在要在政界出名。记住，他想成为印度总督。
So he voted Labour in 1945 to punish the Tories for appeasement. But then he joins the Conservative Research Department, working under the big rising star of the Conservatives, R.A. Butler. And obviously why the Conservatives? Because king and country, romantic traditionalism, the empire, all of that. So you can imagine how shocked he was when Clement Attlee, in early 1947, unveiled the Indian Independence Act. Powell said later he was so upset that he couldn't
所以他在 1945 年投票给工党，以惩罚保守党推行绥靖政策。但随后他加入了保守党研究部，在保守党冉冉升起的大明星 R.A. 巴特勒（R.A. Butler）手下工作。显然为什么是保守党？因为国王与国家、浪漫的传统主义、帝国，所有这些。所以你可以想象当克莱门特·艾德礼（Clement Attlee）在 1947 年初公布《印度独立法案》时，他有多么震惊。鲍威尔后来表示他非常难过，以至于他无法
sleep. He spent the whole night walking the streets of London. And then he came back and he drew a plan to retake India to 10 divisions. And this plan actually got onto Churchill's desk, because Churchill's still Tory leader. And Churchill sort of very sorrowfully said to Powell, it's far too late and we need far more divisions than this. So Powell then did what he often does. He goes completely to the other extreme. He says, the empire is meaningless without India, liquidated at once. It's a great sham. forget all this business about being a great power. He becomes a proper little Englander in the true sense. He believes, you know, England is what matters.
入睡。他整晚都在伦敦街头徘徊。然后他回来制定了一个夺回印度的计划，动用 10 个师。这个计划实际上送到了丘吉尔的办公桌上，因为丘吉尔仍然是保守党领袖。丘吉尔非常悲伤地对鲍威尔说，这太晚了，我们需要比这多得多的师。所以鲍威尔做了他经常做的事。他完全走向了另一个极端。他说，没有印度的帝国毫无意义，立即清算它。这是一个巨大的骗局。忘记所有关于成为大国的生意吧。他成为了一个真正意义上的“小英格兰人”。他相信，你知道，英格兰才是最重要的。
We have come home from our wanderings abroad. We should abandon all our pretensions and just get on with being basically English nationalists. Can I just ask, is it an English nationalism, not a British nationalism then? I mean, what is the attitudes to the United Kingdom? Yeah, this is really interesting. So I think there is always a tension in Powell between, he believes, for example, in the sovereignty of parliament. He thinks Northern Ireland should be part of the United Kingdom like anywhere else. He doesn't believe in Stormont.
我们从国外的流浪中回到了家。我们应该放弃所有的虚荣，继续做基本上是英格兰民族主义者。我能问一下，这是英格兰民族主义，而不是英国民族主义吗？我的意思是，对联合王国的态度是什么？是的，这真的很有趣。所以我认为鲍威尔内心总是存在一种张力，他相信，例如，议会主权。他认为北爱尔兰应该像其他任何地方一样成为联合王国的一部分。他不相信斯托蒙特（Stormont）。
Well, he'll end up an MP for the Ulster Unionists, aren't he? Exactly. But I think Powell is a very, very English figure. All his references are to England. Of course, in the mid-century, people don't often distinguish between England and Britain in the same way they do today. But I think, I mean, I don't just think Powell is the godfather of Brexit or indeed of Thatcherism. I think he's also one of the intellectual godfathers of the kind of revived English nationalism that you've seen in the last 50 years or so. Anyway, Combs MP for Wolverhampton Southwest in February 1950, immediately becomes well known in the House of Commons for the style that I think you captured really well.
嗯，他最终会成为阿尔斯特统一党的议员，不是吗？没错。但我认为鲍威尔是一个非常、非常英格兰的人物。他所有的参考资料都是关于英格兰的。当然，在世纪中叶，人们并不经常像今天这样区分英格兰和英国。但我认为，我的意思是，我不认为鲍威尔只是英国脱欧或撒切尔主义的教父。我认为他也是过去 50 年左右出现的某种复兴的英格兰民族主义的知识教父之一。总之，他在 1950 年 2 月成为伍尔弗汉普顿西南选区的议员，立即以我刚才认为你捕捉得很好的风格在下议院出名。
It's a kind of hypnotic drone, isn't it? It's this kind of West Midlands drone that he does. It's sort of relentless. And he has these speeches which appear to be very coldly, ruthlessly logical. But often underneath there is this kind of simmering passion. I mean, he has these icy, vampiric eyes, doesn't he? Astonishing effect, if you've never seen him speak. Hypnotic is the word.
这是一种催眠般的嗡嗡声，不是吗？这是他那种西米德兰兹的嗡嗡声。它是那种无情的。他发表的演讲看起来非常冷酷、无情地合乎逻辑。但往往在下面有一种这种闷烧的激情。我的意思是，他有那种冰冷的、吸血鬼般的眼睛，不是吗？如果你从未见过他演讲，效果令人震惊。催眠是最好的词。
Exactly. You know, he's not, he's on the right of the Conservative Party economically. He's a laissez-faire kind of classical liberal. but he has lots of friends in the Labour Party. Most famously, Michael Foote and Tony Ben, the two kind of standard bearers of the left famously sort of labour in the 1960s and 70s. And here's a really surprising thing about Powell,
没错。你知道，他不是，他在经济上处于保守党的右翼。他是一个自由放任的古典自由主义者。但他有很多工党的朋友。最著名的是迈克尔·富特（Michael Foot）和托尼·本（Tony Benn），这两个在 1960 年代和 70 年代著名的左翼旗手。关于鲍威尔，有一件非常令人惊讶的事情，
which I imagine those of our listeners who say, oh gosh, she's a terrible man, he's the devil, will be surprised at this. The most famous speech he made before the Rivers of Blood speech was a condemnation, a blazing condemnation of British behaviour in Africa. So in 1959, the British had been, fighting the Mao Mao uprising in Kenya, and 11 Kenyan prisoners have been beaten to death
我想我们那些说“哦天哪，他是个可怕的人，他是恶魔”的听众会对此感到惊讶。他在“血河”演讲之前发表的最著名的演讲是对英国在非洲行为的谴责，一次猛烈的谴责。所以 1959 年，英国一直在肯尼亚打击“茅茅”起义，11 名肯尼亚囚犯被殴打致死
in the Holah-Hola camp. There's a big outcry, and some Tory MPs try to defend it and say, oh, well, it's Africa, you know, who cares what goes on in Africa. And Power gives this blistering speech in the Commons. He says, it's absolutely indefensible. It doesn't matter that it's Africa. Wherever it happens, you know, standards are the same. African lives and worth just as much European lives. This is absolutely intolerable and we should be ashamed in all of this. And loads of MPs on the left at the time came up to him afterwards and said, what a brilliant speech there was. In his memoirs, Dennis Healy, big figure in the Labour Party, said it was, and I quote, the greatest parliamentary speech I ever heard with all the moral passion and rhetorical force
在霍拉霍拉（Hola-Hola）营地。引起了轩然大波，一些保守党议员试图为之辩护，说，哦，好吧，那是非洲，你知道，谁在乎非洲发生了什么。鲍威尔在下议院发表了这篇猛烈的演讲。他说，这是绝对不可辩护的。非洲并不重要。无论它在哪里发生，你知道，标准是一样的。非洲人的生命和欧洲人的生命一样有价值。这是绝对不可容忍的，我们应该为此感到羞耻。当时左翼的许多议员事后走到他面前说，那是一次多么精彩的演讲。丹尼斯·希利（Denis Healey）在回忆录中说，这是，我引用，我听过的最伟大的议会演讲，具有所有的道德激情和修辞力量
of Demosthenes. So Powell would have liked that comparison, wouldn't he? Demosthenes, the great Athenian orator. Yeah, Demosthenes, not a reference, I think, that loads of modernies. and MPs would band it around, don't you think, Tom, slightly depressingly. So you might think, oh, he's a great rising star of the Tories, but actually he's always flouncing out of sort of government, having massive spats with the people running the Tory party. So in 1957, 1958, he has this great row with Harold McMillan
德摩斯梯尼（Demosthenes）的。所以鲍威尔会喜欢那个比较，不是吗？德摩斯梯尼，伟大的雅典演说家。是的，德摩斯梯尼，我认为这不是现代议员会随意引用的参考，你不觉得吗，汤姆，稍微有点令人沮丧。所以你可能认为，哦，他是保守党冉冉升起的大明星，但实际上他总是因为与管理保守党的人发生巨大的争执而愤然离开政府。所以 1957 年、1958 年，他与哈罗德·麦克米伦（Harold Macmillan）发生了巨大的争吵
about inflation and about spending. He walks out because he says spending is too high. McMillan ends up bringing him back as Minister of Health, but deliberately puts him at the far end of the cabinet table because he said, and I quote, I can't stand those mad eyes staring at me a moment longer. So there's always a sense that people are, people are slightly amused by him at this point.
关于通货膨胀和支出。他退出了，因为他说支出太高了。麦克米伦最终让他回来担任卫生大臣，但故意把他放在内阁桌的最远端，因为他说，我引用，我再也无法忍受那双疯狂的眼睛盯着我了。所以人们总是觉得，人们在这一点上对他感到有点好笑。
They see him as a character. You know, he's a bit bonkers, but they think he's very clever. And he's not unclubble, right? Because he's got these friends, both among the Tories, but also in the Labour Party. Then there's another massive row in 1963. Sir Alec Douglas Hume becomes,
他们把他看作一个角色。你知道，他有点疯，但他们认为他非常聪明。而且他不是不可交际的，对吧？因为他有这些朋友，既有保守党人，也有工党人。然后 1963 年又发生了另一次巨大的争吵。亚历克·道格拉斯-休姆（Sir Alec Douglas-Home）爵士成为
Prime Minister, and Powell refuses to serve under him. And actually, one reason he did this, again, may surprise him of our listeners. Paul said of Sir Alex O'Glis Heem, how can I serve under a man whose views on Africa are positively Portuguese? But I suppose by this point, he's given up on the empire. So he would view colonial attempts to keep hold of it as not just immoral, but as a waste of time, as foolish. That's exactly what he thinks, exactly. So the Tories lose in 1964 and Powell seems to have a way back. They have their first ever leadership election in 1965. He stands, he wins only 15 votes, but he says afterwards,
首相，鲍威尔拒绝在他手下任职。事实上，他这样做的一个原因，再次可能会让我们的听众感到惊讶。鲍威尔谈到亚历克·道格拉斯-休姆时说，我怎么能在一个对非洲的看法简直是葡萄牙式的人手下任职？但我认为到这一点，他已经放弃了帝国。所以他会认为殖民地试图保持它的控制不仅是不道德的，而且是浪费时间，是愚蠢的。这正是他所想的，没错。所以保守党在 1964 年输了，鲍威尔似乎有回来的路。他们在 1965 年进行了有史以来第一次领导人选举。他参选，只赢得了 15 票，但他事后说，
I left my visiting card. The new leader, however, is Edward Heath. And Edward Heath, he is not a man for Wagnerian romantic nationalist passions, is he? He loves a committee meeting. Ted Heath loves a quango. But he does love his music too. He does. So that might have been a point of contact, but I can absolutely see your point that Heath is a technocrat and Powell presumably is the least technocratic politician imaginable.
我留下了我的名片。然而，新领袖是爱德华·希思（Edward Heath）。爱德华·希思，他不是一个有瓦格纳式浪漫民族主义激情的人，是吗？他喜欢委员会会议。泰德·希思（Ted Heath）喜欢准自治组织（quango）。但他确实也热爱他的音乐。他确实。所以那可能是一个接触点，但我绝对能看出你的观点，希思是一个技术官僚，而鲍威尔大概是你能想象到的最不具技术官僚色彩的政治家。
Yeah, you're basically asking Richard Wagner and Keir Stama to work together. And I don't feel that's a marriage made in heaven. No. Now, Powell, by this point, it's not just about personalities with Heath, it's also about policy. Power by this point is really becoming a little bit of a professional heretic. So on social issues, for example, he is not conservative. at all. So he is really at odds with the right at the Tory party. He supports legalizing homosexuality. He supports scrapping the death penalty. But on economics, he is way to the other
是的，你基本上是在要求理查德·瓦格纳和基尔·斯塔默（Keir Starmer）一起工作。我不觉得那是天作之合。不。现在，鲍威尔，到这一点，不仅仅是与希思的个性问题，也是政策问题。鲍威尔到这一点真的正在成为一个职业异端。所以关于社会问题，例如，他根本不是保守派。所以他真的与保守党的右翼格格不入。他支持同性恋合法化。他支持废除死刑。但在经济上，他处于另一个
extreme. So he says, you know, the welfare state has a complete bloated monolith. We were spending too much money. We should cut taxes. We're far too left wing. The conservatives have been far too left wing for too long. We should get back to kind of free market values. So in that sense, he's very, very clearly anticipating thatterism in the 1980s. And that means that he is increasingly a man alone in the Tory party. The Sunday Express in 1965 said
极端。所以他说，你知道，福利国家是一个完全臃肿的庞然大物。我们花的钱太多了。我们应该削减税收。我们太左倾了。保守党太左倾太久了。我们应该回到那种自由市场价值观。所以从这个意义上说，他非常、非常清楚地预示了 1980 年代的撒切尔主义。这意味着他在保守党内越来越孤立。1965 年的《星期日快报》说
he has the taut, pale face of a missionary and the zealous energy of a man who's not afraid of the stake. So very savenorola, actually. Yeah. And actually, I was thinking a lot about savenorola, a man whose voice you also did very entertainingly, I have to say.
他有着传教士般紧绷、苍白的脸，以及一个不怕火刑的人那种狂热的能量。所以非常萨沃纳罗拉（Savonarola），实际上。是的。而且实际上，我一直在想很多关于萨沃纳罗拉的事，一个你声音也模仿得非常有趣的人，我必须说。
Thank you, Dominique. That sense of burning, of austerity and burning passion. You know, you see that so often, don't you, with kind of figures who see themselves as prophets in history? Yes. Ted Heath does not care for this at all. And as the months go by, they become increasingly strange. Powell is his defense spokesman. Powell also, actually, I forgot to mention this in the notes, Powell really alienates Heath by coming out massively against the war in Vietnam. Well, he would absolutely come against the war in Vietnam, wouldn't he? Because one of the great themes of his life, which we haven't touched until now, is that he's massively anti-American.
谢谢，多米尼克。那种燃烧感，那种严厉和燃烧的激情。你知道，你经常看到那种，不是吗，那些把自己视为历史先知的人物？是的。泰德·希思根本不在乎这一点。随着几个月的过去，他们变得越来越奇怪。鲍威尔是他的国防发言人。鲍威尔实际上，我忘了在笔记中提到这一点，鲍威尔通过公开强烈反对越南战争，真的疏远了希思。嗯，他绝对会反对越南战争，不是吗？因为他生命中的伟大主题之一，我们直到现在才触及，就是他非常反美。
And that I think stems back to his time in North Africa during the Second World War and his dealings with America. You could argue actually one of the single driving forces in his life is his attitude to America. His hatred really of America and Americanism and his determination that Britain not become in any way American. And we'll come to this in the context of race in the second half. Anyway, it's by about 1966. Powerless becoming increasingly outspoken. He says, it's time for some harsh, fierce, destructive words aimed in defiance and contempt at men and policies we detest.
我认为这源于他在第二次世界大战期间在北非的时光以及他与美国的交往。你实际上可以争辩说，他生命中单一的驱动力之一是他对美国的态度。他真的憎恨美国和美国主义，以及他决心不让英国以任何方式变得美国化。我们将在下半部分关于种族的背景下讨论这一点。总之，大约在 1966 年。鲍威尔变得越来越直言不讳。他说，是时候说一些刺耳、激烈、破坏性的话了，旨在蔑视和鄙视我们厌恶的人和政策。
I mean, Heath is very shocked at this. And Heath says, come on, calm down. To the line, please. And Powell basically ignores him. And it's now that he begins to speak out about one issue above all, which is immigration. And to make sense of this, we need to give a bit of context. So in the first half of the 20th century, I would say, maybe some historians will disagree, but I would say Britain was not by any means a country of immigrants.
我的意思是，希思对此感到非常震惊。希思说，来吧，冷静点。请遵守纪律。而鲍威尔基本上无视他。现在他开始谈论一个高于一切的问题，那就是移民。为了理解这一点，我们需要提供一点背景。所以 20 世纪上半叶，我会说，也许一些历史学家会不同意，但我会说英国绝不是一个移民国家。
Of course there are some black and brown people in port cities and in London and so on and so forth, but they are pretty rare. They are tens of thousands at most in a country of tens of millions. And actually, we did an episode with Trevor Phillips, didn't me, when he was talking about exactly this. And the moment it began to change, the so-called windrush moment in the late 1940s, when you get thousands of immigrants arriving in Britain, basically from the Caribbean and what become India, Pakistan and Bangladesh.
当然，在港口城市和伦敦等地有一些黑人和棕色人种，等等，但他们非常罕见。在数千万人口的国家里，他们最多只有几万人。而且实际上，我们和特雷弗·菲利普斯（Trevor Phillips）做过一期节目，不是吗，当他谈论正是这一点时。它开始改变的那一刻，所谓的 1940 年代末的“疾风号”（Windrush）时刻，当你得到成千上万的移民抵达英国时，基本上来自加勒比海和后来成为印度、巴基斯坦和孟加拉国的地方。
All of them, parts of the British Empire and then British Commonwealth. Exactly. So most of these people go where the jobs are. So they go to industrial cities and manufacturing towns. London at this stage still at an industrial city. They go to Birmingham. They go to the textile towns of Lancashire. And they go, a lot of them go to Powell's own constituency, which is Wolverhampton.
他们所有人，大英帝国的一部分，然后是大英联邦。没错。所以这些人大多数去有工作的地方。所以他们去工业城市和制造业城镇。伦敦在这个阶段仍然是一个工业城市。他们去伯明翰。他们去兰开夏郡的纺织城镇。而且他们去，他们中的很多人去鲍威尔自己的选区，也就是伍尔弗汉普顿。
By the way, for our overseas listeners, Wolverhampton is to the sort of northwest of Birmingham. It's part of the West Midlands conurbation, basically slap bang in the middle of England. Does I have a football team? It has a brilliant football team which invented European football, Wolverhampton Wanderers, one of the oldest and most important football teams in the world. So I'm glad we've mentioned that. Now, right from the start, lots of people were very hostile to immigration on this scale. When the sort of iconic ship, the windrush, arrived in 1948, the Labour government, as we've heard with Trevor Phillips in our episode, was very anxious about it.
顺便说一下，对于我们的海外听众，伍尔弗汉普顿在伯明翰的西北方向。它基本上是西米德兰兹城市群的一部分，就在英格兰的正中间。它有足球队吗？它有一支伟大的足球队，发明了欧洲足球，伍尔弗汉普顿流浪者队，世界上最古老、最重要的足球队之一。所以我很高兴我们提到了这一点。现在，从一开始，很多人就对这种规模的移民非常敌视。当标志性的船只“疾风号”于 1948 年抵达时，工党政府，正如我们在与特雷弗·菲利普斯的节目中听到的那样，对此非常焦虑。
Some Labour MPs complained about it. There are lots of hotels and restaurants that don't allow black or Asian people in. There were always issues with them finding housing. So there was a survey of London landladies in 1953 found that fewer than two out of ten were prepared to let rooms to West Indian immigrants. leaflets that were given by the Ministry of Labor to immigrants made this very clear. You may be refused because you're coloured. You must expect to meet this in Britain. And sometimes, indeed, many people listen to this who remember these years, and we will say often, there is violence.
一些工党议员对此表示抱怨。有很多酒店和餐馆不允许黑人或亚洲人进入。他们寻找住房总是存在问题。所以 1953 年对伦敦女房东的一项调查发现，不到十分之二的人准备把房间租给西印度移民。劳工部发给移民的传单非常清楚地说明了这一点。你可能会因为你是色人种而被拒绝。你必须预料到在英国会遇到这种情况。有时，事实上，许多听这些节目的人记得这些年，我们经常会说，有暴力。
So you often read about attacks on boarding houses where, for example, Caribbean or Asian people are living. There are racist riots in Nottingham and Notting Hill in 1958. And under all this sort of pressure, the Tory government of the days decides to change the system. So, Tom, you mentioned that they're coming from places within the empire, and often they've been invited to come. Under the British Nationality Act in 1948, 800 million people had the right to come and live in Britain. And nobody had anticipated there would be a massive influx. Am I right that one of the things that Powell starts to obsess about is the fact that people who live in the United Kingdom have exactly the same legal status as subjects under the crown
所以你经常读到对寄宿公寓的袭击，例如，加勒比海或亚洲人居住的地方。1958 年在诺丁汉和诺丁山发生了种族骚乱。在所有这种压力下，当时的保守党政府决定改变制度。所以，汤姆，你提到他们来自帝国境内的地区，而且他们经常被邀请来。根据 1948 年的《英国国籍法》，8 亿人有权来英国居住。没有人预料到会有大规模涌入。我说的对吗，鲍威尔开始痴迷的一件事是，居住在联合王国的人与王室下的臣民拥有完全相同的法律地位
as people in kind of overseas territories, and that therefore there is no kind of British citizenship in the way that there's American or French citizenship. And therefore, he comes to worry about what is it that distinguishes people who live in, say, England from people who live in the Caribbean, legally. Yeah, he's obsessed with all the sort of legal details of these kinds of things. So a really good example, actually. Slightly tangential to what you're talking about is he has a massive being his bonus about the queen's official title because it says that she's the queen of her other realms and territories. And he says, well, does this mean? It's meaningless. Her other realms and territories. It could mean anything. Remorseless logic, driving him mad.
就像海外领土的人一样，因此没有像美国或法国公民身份那样的英国公民身份。因此，他开始担心，在法律上，居住在例如英格兰的人与居住在加勒比海的人有什么区别。是的，他痴迷于这类事情的所有法律细节。所以一个很好的例子，实际上。与你谈论的内容略有偏离的是，他因为女王的官方头衔而有一个巨大的心结，因为它说她是她其他王国和领土的女王。他说，嗯，这意味着什么？这毫无意义。她其他王国和领土。它可能意味着任何事情。无情的逻辑，让他发疯。
And everyone's kind of like this and like with the citizenship stuff, everybody else is sort of saying, pipe down, Enoch. You know, it's fine, it's a fudge. Don't worry about it. You're overthinking it. But he's a massive overthinker. I mean, he really, you know, he will spend ages obsessing about these kinds of details, the details of citizenship and stuff. Yeah, if there's a rabbit hole, he'll go down it. Well, he does that later on, doesn't he with the, is it the New Testament or something? He writes all this biblical scholarship with other people, biblical scholars, I think is a bit bonkers.
每个人都像这样，就像公民身份的事情一样，其他人都在说，闭嘴，伊诺克。你知道，没关系，这是一个权宜之计。别担心。你考虑得太多了。但他是一个巨大的过度思考者。我的意思是，他真的，你知道，他会花很长时间痴迷于这类细节，公民身份的细节等等。是的，如果有一个兔子洞，他就会钻进去。嗯，他后来确实那样做了，不是吗，关于，是新约还是什么？他和别人一起写了所有这些圣经学术研究，圣经学者，我想有点疯。
Anyway, by the late 50s, it's very clear that most people in Britain hate immigration on this scale. I mean, there's no other way of putting it. Polls show that about three out of four people strongly dislike it. they want the government to shut the doors. So in 1962, Harold McMillan did shut the doors. The Commonwealth Immigrants Act brings in controls for Commonwealth citizens who haven't been born in Britain. The unanticipated consequence is that in the months before the Act becomes law,
总之，到 50 年代末，很明显，英国大多数人讨厌这种规模的移民。我的意思是，没有其他说法。民意调查显示，大约四分之三的人强烈不喜欢它。他们希望政府关上大门。所以 1962 年，哈罗德·麦克米伦确实关上了大门。《英联邦移民法案》对未在英国出生的英联邦公民实施了管制。未预料到的后果是，在该法案成为法律之前的几个月里，
there's a huge rush for people to get into Britain. 150,000 people arrive from the Caribbean, India and Pakistan to beat the deadline. And then another unanticipated consequence, I think Trevor Phillips talked about this in the episode we did with him. The people who have arrived have been predominantly young men. And they've now settled down. They haven't gone home, as many of them expected to. They decide they quite like it.
人们涌入英国的浪潮巨大。15 万人从加勒比海、印度和巴基斯坦抵达，以赶在截止日期前。然后是另一个未预料到的后果，我想特雷弗·菲利普斯在我们和他做的节目中谈到了这一点。抵达的人主要是年轻人。他们现在安顿下来了。他们没有回家，正如他们中的许多人预期的那样。他们决定他们相当喜欢这里。
And they want to bring their family dependence with them, wives, you know, children, aged parents, and so on and so forth. And so you get a continued influx in the 1960s. And so by the late 1960s, the Caribbean and South Asian-born population has risen 10 times in 20 years. now, what is it, about 700,000, and it'll be around about a million by the beginning of the 1970s. Now, you might expect a populist reaction to all this. You know, that's what we see today, right? The higher the immigration figures go, the more that kind of populist parties thrive. But at the time, I think the remarkable thing, having written about this, is how muted the reaction is. You know, most MPs, I think, recognize that they think immigration is a regrettable
他们想把家属也带过来，妻子、孩子、年迈的父母等等。因此，20世纪60年代人口持续涌入。到60年代末，加勒比和南亚裔人口在20年间增长了10倍。现在大约有70万人，到70年代初将达到100万人左右。你可能会预料到对此会有民粹主义的反应。你知道，这就是我们今天所看到的，对吧？移民数字越高，那种民粹主义政党就越兴旺。但在当时，我认为令人瞩目的是，写过这段历史后，我发现当时的反应是多么的克制。你知道，我认为大多数议员都认识到，他们认为移民是一种令人遗憾的
necessity because the economy needs this cheap, unskilled labour. I think also a lot of labour MPs are committed to a kind of slightly woolly, you know, citizens of the world, kind of internationalism. That's why Harold Wilson loves the Commonwealth, for example. Well, it's interesting that you allied the two, because I wonder whether that is, you know, the kind of the woolly internationalism is a kind of slightly distorted form of the imperial impulse that inspired so many generations of upper class and middle class Britons to go abroad? I think it absolutely is. And so that is something that Powell would despise.
必要之举，因为经济需要这种廉价、非熟练的劳动力。我也认为许多工党议员致力于一种稍微有些模糊的、你知道的，“世界公民”式的国际主义。这就是为什么哈罗德·威尔逊喜欢英联邦的原因。嗯，你把这两者联系起来很有趣，因为我怀疑那种模糊的国际主义是否是一种稍微扭曲的帝国冲动，这种冲动激励了那么多代中上层英国人去海外？我认为绝对是这样。所以这正是鲍威尔所鄙视的。
Exactly. I think he has no time for any of this kind of stuff because he is, once he realizes he can't become viceroy of India, it's over. Why are you still persisting in this ridiculous charade? Yeah. And of course, Tory MPs, most Tory MPs, or at least a lot of Tory MPs, are still stirred by, you know, the Raj and General Gordon and all this kind of. of thing. And for that reason, they don't want to turn their backs on relics and memories
没错。我认为他根本不屑于这种东西，因为他一旦意识到自己无法成为印度总督，一切就结束了。你为什么还要坚持这种荒谬的闹剧？是的。当然，保守党议员，大多数保守党议员，或者至少很多保守党议员，仍然被英属印度、戈登将军以及所有这类事情所触动。正因如此，他们不想背弃帝国的遗迹和记忆。
of empire. The idea, you know, Kivas Britannicus sum, actually, you know, you hear that phrase in the 1950s and 1960s. And Powell, precisely perhaps because he can, he can still feel the tug of that, is all the more contemptuous of it. He's kind of guarding against his own romantic impulses, perhaps. I think that's very astute. I think that there is a bit of him, I always think that they're probably nostalgic for all that, and he's fighting against it. I think you're absolutely right. So immigration isn't really a massive national issue until 1964,
那种“我是罗马公民”的观念，实际上，你知道，你在20世纪50年代和60年代还能听到这句话。而鲍威尔，或许正是因为他还能感受到那种牵引力，所以才更加蔑视它。他可能是在防范自己内心浪漫的冲动。我认为这非常敏锐。我认为他内心深处有一部分，我总觉得他们可能对这一切怀有怀旧之情，而他正在与之抗争。我想你是完全正确的。所以移民问题直到1964年才真正成为一个巨大的国家议题，
and it happens literally on the road between Birmingham, where Powell was born and Wolverhampton, the town he represents just up the road, in a place called Smethwick in the West Midlands Manufacturing Heartland, which had been known since Victorian times as the black country. So Smedic was a town of about 70,000 people, run down, manufacturing town, very limited housing, one in ten of its population are immigrants. In 1964, the tour is picked as their candidate, a local councillor called Peter Griffiths, who had already made a stir in the constituency by saying, and I quote, Labour are the immigrants friends. And during the campaign, posters and stickers go up across the constituency with the incredibly inflammatory slogan.
它实际上发生在伯明翰（鲍威尔出生地）和伍尔弗汉普顿（他所代表的城镇，就在路边）之间的路上，在一个叫斯梅斯威克的地方，位于西米德兰兹制造业中心地带，自维多利亚时代以来就被称为“黑乡”。斯梅斯威克是一个约有7万人口的城镇，破败不堪，制造业城镇，住房非常有限，十分之一的人口是移民。1964年，保守党选择了当地议员彼得·格里菲斯作为候选人，他已经在选区引起了轰动，他说，我引用一下，“工党是移民的朋友”。在竞选期间，整个选区贴满了海报和贴纸，上面写着极其煽动性的口号。
If you want a neighbour, vote Liberal or Labour. I think the listeners can probably forgive me for not using the word. And the result is a swing to the Tories of more than 7% in an election that nationally the Tories lose. And Griffith wins the seat. And this is a big shock to people. You know, when he arrived in the House of Commons, a lot of people turned their backs on him, wouldn't shake his hand, all of this kind of thing. Harold Wilson said he was a parliamentary leper. But at the time, some of the papers, for example, at the Times says, this has been coming.
如果你想要个邻居，就投自由党或工党。我想听众大概能原谅我不说出那个词。结果是保守党在全国选举中失利的情况下，在该选区获得了超过7%的摇摆票。格里菲斯赢得了席位。这对人们来说是一个巨大的冲击。你知道，当他到达下议院时，很多人背对着他，不愿与他握手，诸如此类。哈罗德·威尔逊称他为“议会麻风病人”。但在当时，一些报纸，例如《泰晤士报》说，这是迟早要来的。
You know, the Times says, on this subject, immigration, there is a great gulf between the ordinary man in the street and the leaders of public opinion in Parliament, the churches, the intelligency of the press and so on. And some people in the Labour Party, like Richard Crossman, who's one of Wilson's ministers, say, you know, we should be careful about this. Because if we don't, you know, if we're not seen as being on the right side of public opinion, we could be swept away on this issue. I mean, definite echoes with the present, I think, Tom. But, you know, the months go by, the issue seems to calm down. Griffith, but ultimately is a nobody. You know, he's a mediocrity.
你知道，《泰晤士报》说，关于移民这个话题，普通民众与议会、教会、新闻界知识分子等舆论领袖之间存在巨大的鸿沟。工党内的一些人，比如威尔逊的部长之一理查德·克罗斯曼，说，你知道，我们应该对此小心。因为如果我们不这样做，如果我们不被视为站在公众舆论正确的一边，我们可能会在这个问题上被扫地出门。我的意思是，我认为这与现在有明确的呼应，汤姆。但是，你知道，几个月过去了，这个问题似乎平静了下来。格里菲斯，归根结底是个无名小卒。你知道，他是个平庸之辈。
He's not remotely capable of the national campaign. But then a much more serious politician decides that he is going to embrace the issue. And this man, of course, is Enoch Powell. Well, Dominic, you have set up the context for Powell's most notorious speech, and after the break, we will come to the rivers of blood. Hello, everyone, welcome back to The Rest is History, and we are in mid-60s Britain. Everything's groovy, or is it? Because Enoch Powell, who I think is definitely not groovy, he's a brilliant classicist, as we've heard, At one point, he wanted to be the viceroy of India. He's also a blistering critic of imperial atrocities committed by Britain.
他根本没有能力发起全国性的运动。但随后一位更严肃的政治家决定拥抱这个问题。这个人当然就是伊诺克·鲍威尔。好吧，多米尼克，你已经为鲍威尔最臭名昭著的演讲铺垫了背景，休息之后，我们将讨论“血河”演讲。大家好，欢迎回到《历史的其余部分》，我们正处于60年代中期的英国。一切都很时髦，是吗？因为伊诺克·鲍威尔，我认为他绝对不时髦，他是一位杰出的古典学者，正如我们所听到的，他曾一度想成为印度总督。他也是英国帝国暴行的猛烈批评者。
He is preparing to give the speech that will make him a hero to the far right in Britain. And Dominic, how do we get there? How does Powell get there? Right. Well, first of all, Powell in the 50s and early 60s had never seemed very interested in race, in the politics of immigration. But his constituency, Wolverhampton, is right at the heart of the immigration issue. You know, it's a kind of Midlands, industrial, metal-bashing town. It had boomed in the 50s.
他正准备发表那篇将使他成为英国极右翼英雄的演讲。多米尼克，我们是怎么走到这一步的？鲍威尔是怎么走到这一步的？好吧，首先，鲍威尔在50年代和60年代初似乎对种族、移民政治并不太感兴趣。但他的选区伍尔弗汉普顿正处于移民问题的核心。你知道，这是一个米德兰兹地区的工业、金属加工城镇。它在50年代曾繁荣一时。
There was a massive demand for labour. And in had come thousands of young men from the Caribbean, from India, from Pakistan, working in their local factories and the foundries. So by the mid-1960s, Wolverhampton had a higher concentration of immigrants than any other town or city apart from London. And at first, there was remarkably little pushback, I would say, from the sort of town's opinion formers. So the local Express and Star still exists. It was the biggest regional paper, and I think it still is, by far, in Britain. And it was a conservative
当时对劳动力的需求巨大。成千上万来自加勒比、印度、巴基斯坦的年轻人来到这里，在当地的工厂和铸造厂工作。因此，到60年代中期，伍尔弗汉普顿的移民集中度比除伦敦以外的任何城镇或城市都要高。起初，我认为来自该镇舆论引导者的抵制非常少。所以当地的《快报与星报》至今仍然存在。它是英国最大的区域性报纸，我想现在仍然是，遥遥领先。它是一份保守党
supporting paper, as I think it still is. The Express and Star said, these people are British citizens, this is going back to Akivas Britannicus stuff, Tom, British citizens with a perfect right to come here and try and earn a living. Many of them are better behaved than some of their white cousins in this country. You know, it's like patronising language, but it could be worse. It could be a lot worse. But over time, you start to see some tensions growing. What's happening in towns across Britain and cities is older working class residents
支持的报纸，我想现在依然是。当时《快报与星报》说，这些人是英国公民，这又回到了“我是罗马公民”那一套，汤姆，英国公民完全有权来到这里并努力谋生。他们中的许多人比这个国家的一些白人同胞表现得更好。你知道，这是一种居高临下的语言，但情况可能会更糟。可能会糟糕得多。但随着时间的推移，你开始看到一些紧张局势在加剧。英国各城镇和城市正在发生的事情是，年长的工人阶级居民
are moving out to the suburbs, to the counties. Immigrants move in. The house prices start to fall. And those residents who haven't moved out start to feel jittery, that their house price is going to fall and they're surrounded by people they don't know and so on and so forth. So white flight is the phrase, isn't it? White flight. I mean, it's a very, very familiar story. Now, most of the newcomers are young single men. We've already made that point. Inevitably, you know, they want to play their music. They want to have a good time. They have parties. So you start
正搬往郊区和郡县。移民搬了进来。房价开始下跌。那些没有搬走的居民开始感到不安，担心房价会下跌，而且他们被自己不认识的人包围着，等等。所以“白人逃离”就是这个词，不是吗？白人逃离。我的意思是，这是一个非常、非常熟悉的故事。现在，大多数新来者是年轻的单身男性。我们已经提到了这一点。不可避免地，你知道，他们想放音乐。他们想玩得开心。他们开派对。所以你开始
to get all these stories, you know, oh, they don't behave. Oh, they play their music. Oh, they they drink and all this kind of thing. And you get local residents associations complaining. But what does Enoch Powell do? At first, he does absolutely nothing at all as one of the town's MPs. So in 1959, his beaten Labour opponent in the general election actually went out of his way to say, I respect Mr Powell for not exploiting the immigration issue. In 1961, a group of anti-immigration residents went to ask for his support.
听到所有这些故事，你知道，哦，他们表现不好。哦，他们放音乐。哦，他们喝酒，诸如此类。你开始听到当地居民协会的抱怨。但伊诺克·鲍威尔做了什么？起初，作为该镇的议员之一，他什么也没做。所以1959年，他在大选中击败的工党对手实际上特意说，我尊重鲍威尔先生没有利用移民问题。1961年，一群反移民的居民去寻求他的支持。
And one of them, a welder, said afterwards, He was all for the immigrants. We had a lot of examples of their dirty, filthy habits, and we asked him to make a fuss about them, but we didn't get any satisfaction from him. Like Mick Jagger. Yes, like Mick Jagger. Then in 1964, you get the first sign of him making a change.
其中一个人，一名焊工，事后说：“他完全支持移民。我们有很多关于他们肮脏、污秽习惯的例子，我们要求他对此大惊小怪，但我们没有从他那里得到任何满足。”就像米克·贾格尔一样。是的，就像米克·贾格尔。然后到了1964年，你看到了他做出改变的第一个迹象。
He says, it is essential to have strict controls if we are to avoid the evils of a colour question in this country. So it's sort of, it's for the immigrants' own good that we start to bring in controls. And by the colour question, By that, is he thinking of the United States? I think you cannot understand this issue without realizing that in an age when for the first time, I think about in 1964, when he makes the speech, is the point of which TV ownership has reached saturation point, everybody who's ever going to get a TV has got one, and they are watching the news from Selma, Alabama, you know, from Montgomery, from all these kinds of places, this is on their mind the whole time.
他说：“如果我们想避免这个国家出现种族问题的弊端，严格的控制是必不可少的。”所以这有点像是，为了移民自己的利益，我们开始引入控制。关于“种族问题”，他是在想美国吗？我认为如果不意识到这一点，你就无法理解这个问题：在那个时代，我认为大约在1964年他发表演讲时，电视普及率达到了饱和点，所有打算买电视的人都已经买了一台，他们正在观看来自阿拉巴马州塞尔玛、蒙哥马利等所有这些地方的新闻，这始终在他们的脑海中。
because it's making the headlines. You know, Martin Luther King's campaigns, the racist backlash in the, you know, formerly Confederate South, all of that stuff. That's in the ether. It's absolutely there. Now, at the same time when he writes that in 1964, he also writes a piece for the local paper that's often quoted later.
因为这成了头条新闻。你知道，马丁·路德·金的运动，前邦联南方地区的种族主义反弹，所有这些东西。这都在空气中。它绝对在那里。现在，当他在1964年写下这些话时，他也为当地报纸写了一篇文章，后来经常被引用。
I always will set my face like Flint against making any difference between one citizen of this country and another on the grounds of his origin. Now, that's a phrase that I think, I think he backs away from that position later on. I think because I think he comes to think that where people have come from is tremendously important, but the implication here is that he doesn't think it's important at all. Anyway, I'll just leave that hanging. In the next few years, as he is fording out with his new leader, Ted Heath, he's sharpening
“我将永远像燧石一样坚定，反对根据出身的不同，在这个国家的公民之间制造任何区别。”现在，这是一个我认为，我认为他后来退出了这个立场。因为我认为他开始认为人们来自哪里非常重要，但这里的暗示是他根本不认为这很重要。总之，我就把这个悬而未决。在接下来的几年里，当他与新领导人泰德·希思发生争执时，他正在磨砺
his tone. He starts to say, there's a taboo on this issue. And to talk about immigration, you know, it's not color prejudice or racial. intolerant to ask for strict controls. Now, at first, I think people don't really notice because he's saying all kinds of eccentric things. You know, let's not help the Americans in Vietnam. Let's cut all the spending on the welfare states, all of this kind of stuff. But if you track what he's actually saying month by month, it's clearly becoming more and more aggressive. So by 1965, in the spring in 1965, he starts saying two things. One, we should stop allowing people's
他的语气。他开始说，这个问题有一个禁忌。谈论移民，你知道，要求严格控制并不是种族偏见或种族不宽容。起初，我认为人们并没有真正注意到，因为他在说各种古怪的事情。你知道，让我们不要在越南帮助美国人。让我们削减所有福利国家的开支，所有这些东西。但如果你追踪他每个月实际说的话，它显然变得越来越激进。所以到1965年，1965年春天，他开始说两件事。第一，我们应该停止允许人们的
wives and children to join them in Britain. And two, it's time for some people to go home. We should start encouraging them to go back home, basically not forcing them, but with systems of subsidies and whatnot. Why is he doing this? Why has he adopted this issue and why is his tone becoming harder? Powell always said, I'm simply reflecting the views of my Wolverhampton constituents. And I think there is, to be fair to him, an element of truth in this. A lot of manufacturing in towns in mid-60s Britain. If you forget about immigration, just look at what's happening in these towns. They're quite run down.
妻子和孩子来英国与他们团聚。第二，是时候让一些人回家了。我们应该开始鼓励他们回家，基本上不是强迫他们，而是通过补贴制度等等。他为什么要这样做？他为什么要采纳这个问题，为什么他的语气变得越来越强硬？鲍威尔总是说，我只是在反映我伍尔弗汉普顿选民的观点。而且我认为，公平地说，这其中有真实的成分。60年代中期英国城镇的制造业。如果你忘记移民，只看看这些城镇正在发生什么。它们相当破败。
You know, the sort of, the Victorian fabric of these places is visibly fraying. Their industries are running into foreign competition. British productivity is atrocious. People are becoming increasingly anxious about rising prices and losing their jobs. The sort of, yes, the swinging 60s is going on in Carnaby Street. but actually a lot of people feel very shut out and left behind, as they do today, actually. So basically, hard times breed, hardening opinions? I think so.
你知道，这些地方的维多利亚时代建筑结构明显在磨损。它们的工业正面临外国竞争。英国的生产力极其糟糕。人们对物价上涨和失业越来越感到焦虑。是的，卡纳比街上确实有摇摆的60年代，但实际上很多人感到非常被排斥和被抛弃，就像今天一样，实际上。所以基本上，艰难时期滋生了强硬的观点？我想是这样。
And I think this is where I think I would argue in flattering myself a more nuanced attitude to how people think about immigration than they're all just racists or they're anti-racists. I think it's not necessarily that people blame immigrants personally for these things, but I think they see immigration and the presence of immigrants. as yet another symptom of a more generalised kind of decline. And a symptom that maybe means an awful lot to them. But I think they would say a lot of people, you see it again and again in interviews actually. People, especially older people, will say, everything is changing.
我认为这就是我对自己认为人们如何看待移民的态度进行更细致的辩护的地方，而不是说他们都是种族主义者或反种族主义者。我认为人们不一定是因为这些事情而个人责怪移民，但我认为他们将移民和移民的存在视为更普遍衰落的又一个症状。一个可能对他们意义重大的症状。但我认为他们会说，很多人，你实际上在采访中一次又一次地看到这一点。人们，尤其是老年人，会说，一切都在改变。
You know, the street feels different, the town feels different, no one cares about us. And so they care about immigration both in and of itself, but also as a symbol of something deeper and more kind of inchoate. And does Powell share these opinions? because he's a very romantic, conservative, adores Parliament, and the great conservative, romantic opinion of Parliament expressed by Edmund Burke is that the duty of a member of parliament
你知道，街道感觉不同了，城镇感觉不同了，没有人关心我们。所以他们关心移民，既是因为移民本身，也是因为它作为某种更深层、更模糊事物的象征。鲍威尔是否认同这些观点？因为他是一个非常浪漫、保守的人，崇拜议会，而埃德蒙·伯克所表达的伟大的保守、浪漫的议会观点是，议员的职责
is to speak his own opinions and not just to serve as a kind of loud speaker for opinions of constituents. Well, this is one of the issues, right? That he owes his electors, he owes them his judgment. He's not, as you say, he's not just their sort of, a loud speaker for them. And the thing is, Powell doesn't live in Wolverhampton. Powell lives in Belgravia,
是表达自己的观点，而不是仅仅充当选民观点的扩音器。好吧，这就是问题之一，对吧？他欠选民的，他欠他们的是他的判断力。他不是，正如你所说，他不仅仅是他们的某种扩音器。问题是，鲍威尔不住在伍尔弗汉普顿。鲍威尔住在贝尔格莱维亚，
in the swankiest part of London. He has never really shown that much interest in what, you know, the men who stand on the Molyneux terraces on a Saturday cheering the finest team in the Midlands. They actually are the finest team in the Midlands, by the way, at this point, they're not merely the finest team in the Midlands. They became champions of the world in the mid-1950s. So, yeah, you can suck on that just for a second.
伦敦最时髦的地方。他从未真正表现出对那些周六站在莫利纽克斯看台上为米德兰兹最好的球队欢呼的人们所想的事情有多大兴趣。顺便说一句，他们确实是米德兰兹最好的球队，在这一点上，他们不仅仅是米德兰兹最好的球队。他们在50年代中期成为了世界冠军。所以，是的，你可以为此吸一口气。
Well, we're running out of times. We need to move on, but I mean, that is an outrageous and ludicrous statement. He's not really interested in what they think, I would say, up to this point. You know, he's never been the Tribune of the Plex. He's always been a man apart. So why is he doing it? I think it's complicated. I think Powell has always been obsessively interested in English identity.
好吧，我们的时间不多了。我们需要继续前进，但我的意思是，这是一个令人愤慨和荒谬的陈述。我会说，直到这一点，他并不真正关心他们的想法。你知道，他从来都不是平民的代言人。他一直是一个超然的人。那么他为什么要这样做？我认为这很复杂。我认为鲍威尔一直对英国身份有着强迫性的兴趣。
And he has this idea, to use his own words, he says, Our national identity is based on, and I quote, the continuous life of a united people and its island home. And this idea of the united people and the island home, he comes to think that the advent of so many newcomers is diluting and undermining that. And I think what happens is once he's first articulated the idea, it clearly chimes with a lot of people,
他有这个想法，用他自己的话来说，他说：“我们的国家身份基于，”我引用，“一个团结的人民及其岛屿家园的持续生活。”而这种关于团结的人民和岛屿家园的想法，他开始认为这么多新来者的到来正在稀释和破坏这一点。我认为发生的事情是，一旦他第一次阐述了这个想法，它显然与很多人产生了共鸣，
and he almost self-radicalizes. It's like the process that you see on social media. He makes the speech, he gets lots, He got a better reaction than for any other speech he's ever made. And then he thinks, well, I'll give people more. People clearly want this. And I like doing this. And he goes further and further.
他几乎自我激进化了。这就像你在社交媒体上看到的过程。他发表了演讲，他得到了很多，他得到的反应比他发表过的任何其他演讲都要好。然后他想，好吧，我会给人们更多。人们显然想要这个。而且我喜欢这样做。于是他走得越来越远。
And the point about Powell is he will always pursue an idea to its absolute kind of logical extreme, driven mad by his own remorse. That's logic. Exactly. And then the other element, and an element I think that is often missing from a lot of accounts. This is personal for him and it's political. It's a way for him to distinguish himself from, you know, Mr. Boring. Ted Heath, the Kirstarmer of kind of Tory politics and the 60s and 70s. So a committee man, a pragmatist, somebody who loves a bit of a fudge and a compromise. This is a brilliant way
关于鲍威尔的一点是，他总是会把一个想法追求到其绝对的逻辑极端，被他自己的悔恨逼疯了。那是逻辑。没错。然后是另一个因素，我认为在很多叙述中经常被遗漏的因素。这对他来说是私人的，也是政治的。这是他将自己与，你知道，无聊先生泰德·希思（60和70年代保守党政治中的基尔·斯塔默）区分开来的一种方式。所以一个委员会成员，一个实用主义者，一个喜欢一点敷衍和妥协的人。这是一个绝妙的方法
for Powell to tell the world, I'm not Ted Heath, and to appeal to Tory grassroots people who are not really interested in his views on Herodotus or Nietzsche or A.e. Houseman, but they really respond to all this kind of stuff. And at this point, he still wants to be prime minister? Oh, yeah. I think he's very ambitious, his pal, very ambitious. So by 1967, he's now making comparisons with America all the time. And he says, look at the riots in American cities.
让鲍威尔告诉世界，我不是泰德·希思，并吸引那些对他在希罗多德、尼采或A.E.豪斯曼方面的观点不感兴趣，但对所有这些东西有强烈反应的保守党基层民众。在这一点上，他仍然想成为首相吗？哦，是的。我认为他非常有野心，鲍威尔，非常有野心。所以到1967年，他现在一直在与美国进行比较。他说，看看美国城市的骚乱。
This is what is coming to Britain, if we're not careful. And he actually uses some phrases that I think even his defenders will say, oh, hold on, this is. So he says to Heath at one point, he says, in Wolverhampton, I've seen, yes, I've seen white racism, and that is terrible. but he also says I have seen insolence by coloured against white and corresponding fearfulness on the part of white and I have to say when I came across that word I mean I wrote about this 20 years ago and then when I was preparing this episode I was rereading the stuff
如果我们不小心，这就是即将来到英国的事情。他甚至使用了一些我认为即使是他的辩护者也会说，哦，等等，这是……的短语。所以他在某个时候对希思说，他说，在伍尔弗汉普顿，我看到了，是的，我看到了白人种族主义，那很可怕。但他还说，我看到了有色人种对白人的傲慢，以及白人方面相应的恐惧，我必须说，当我遇到那个词时——我的意思是，我20年前写过这个，然后当我准备这一集时，我正在重读关于我们的东西——那个词“傲慢”一下子跳了出来，那是一个你在美国南方使用的词，当你在说黑人没有向白人妇女脱帽致敬或者其他什么的时候，太沉重了。我的意思是，有趣的是，我的意思是，我总是记得我们做的关于夏威夷国王的那一集，他乘火车穿越英国时非常震惊，如果他买了票，坐在英国火车车厢里，他并没有感到自己傲慢。然后他穿过美国，却被赶了出去，因为作为一个被认为是黑人的人，他不被允许待在里面。所以这对他自己的英国感来说是相当陌生的。我的意思是，英国人通常为他们不像美国南方人那样对待黑人而感到自豪。但鲍威尔在那里所做的事情，讽刺的是，考虑到他的反美主义，是采取了一种美国式的语调。我想是这样。我想是这样。而且我认为这
on us that word insolence just jumped out that is a word that you use in the American South when you're saying the black bloke hasn't dothed his hat to the white woman or whatever it is so loaded I mean, what's interesting is, I mean, I always remember the episode we did on the King of Hawaii, who was very struck crossing Britain by rail, that there was no sense of that he was being insolent by sitting in a British railway carriage if he'd bought his ticket. And then he goes across America and gets chucked out because as someone who is taken for black, he's not allowed to be in it. So it is kind of quite alien to the British sense of themselves. I mean, British people are often proud that they don't treat black people in the way that. people in the American South do. But what Powell is doing there, ironically, considering his anti-Americanism, is to adopt an American tone. I think so. I think so. And I think this
开始变得更有意义了，当你在美国正在发生的事情的背景下看待罗里的整个观点时。实际上，还有非洲正在发生的事情。因为在1967年底，非洲的事件发挥了作用。因为肯尼亚总统乔莫·肯雅塔决定驱逐20万肯尼亚亚裔，他们最初是英国帝国时期来到肯尼亚的印度商人和劳工。他们要去哪里？他们中的许多人持有英国护照。显而易见的地方是英国，古老的帝国母国。引起了巨大的愤怒。鲍威尔公开表示。他说让这些人进入英国是疯狂的。他们应该回到他们所属的国家。那在哪里？这意味着什么？印度，
starts to make much more sense, this whole view of Rory, when you view it in the context of what's going on in America. Also, actually, what's going on in Africa. Because at the end of 1967, events in Africa come into play. Because Jomo Kenyatta, the president of Kenya, decides to kick out the 200,000 Kenyan Asians, originally Indian merchants and labourers who have come to Kenya during the British Empire. Where are they going to go? Many of them got British passports. The obvious place to go is Britain, the old imperial motherland. There's a massive furority. Powell speaks out. He says it's mad to let these people into Britain. They should return to the country where they belong. And where is that? The implication of that is what? India,
也许，尽管当然，他们中的许多人从未踏足过印度。鲍威尔在这一点上并不是唯一的声音。1967年底，所以我们刚刚经历了美国所谓的1967年“漫长炎热的夏天”，数百个城市被骚乱和纵火所吞噬等等。所以工党，哈罗德·威尔逊政府，对此感到非常惊慌。他们匆忙通过了一项紧急法案，基本上是为了阻止肯尼亚亚裔进入英国，剥夺他们许多人进入英国的权利，实行严格的配额，当时许多保守党媒体，实际上是保守党媒体，不仅仅是
maybe, although, of course, many of them have never, they've never set foot in India. Pals is not a lone voice at this point. Late 1967, so we've just been through what's called the Long Hot Summer of 1967 in America, hundreds of cities consumed by rioting and arson and so on. So Labor, the Harold Wilson government, are kind of very alarmed by this. They rush through an emergency bill to basically stop the Kenyan Asians coming to Britain, to strip many of them of their right to come to Britain, with strict quotas, a lot of the Tory press at the time, actually the Tory press, not just the
工党媒体，说这令人难以置信，这是不合情理的。《旁观者》杂志称这是议会通过的最不道德的立法之一，但它还是通过了。工党为什么要这样做？他们是在回应选区基层的压力吗？是的。所以有一个非常著名的，在这个节目里听了很长时间的人，我知道我是詹姆斯·卡拉汉的忠实粉丝。这绝不是卡拉汉最好的一天。他是内政大臣。有那么一点，我想他的同事之一，
Labour press, said this was unbelievably, this was unconscionable. The spectator said it was one of those immoral pieces of legislation ever to go through Parliament, but it went through all the same. Why is Labour doing this? Are they responding to grassroots pressure in their constituencies? Yes. Right. So there's a very famous, everyone in this, you listened to this podcast for a long time, I know I'm a big fan of James Callaghan. this is not Callahan's finest dad by any means. He's home secretary. There's a point at which, I think one of his colleagues,
理查德·克罗斯曼，在他的日记中写道，他说，吉姆在工党中为自己赢得了很大的名声，你知道，因为他下定决心，吉姆向我们的支持者传达的信息是，我引用，“不再有该死的移民，无论发生什么。”而想法是，工党会通过这个信息做得很好。很多工人阶级会喜欢它。没错。所以同样，在当前的政治中并不陌生。
Richard Crossman, writes in his diary and he says, Jim's making a big name for himself in the Labour Party, you know, because he is determined the message that Jim is sending to our supporters is, and I quote, no more bloody immigrants, whatever happens. And the thinking is, Labour will do very well with this message. Lots of working class people will like it. Right. So again, not unknown in current politics.
但当然，他们认为自己是好人，对吧，工党。所以他们想用一些更进步的立法来平衡这一点，即《种族关系法案》，以消除住房和就业方面的歧视。现在，这很重要，因为这将是鲍威尔“血河”演讲的导火索。他们想引入这种友善、可爱的种族关系法案。泰德·希思对他的同事说，好吧，我们不是种族主义者。所以我们不想，我们不想疯狂地反对这一点。我们要做的就是对细节吹毛求疵，因为反对派就是这么做的，
But of course, they see themselves as the good guys, right, the Labour Party. So they want to counterbalance this with a bit more progressive legislation, which is a race relations bill to stamp out discrimination in housing and employment. Now, this is important because this is going to be the trigger for Powell's Rivers of Blood Speech. They want to introduce this sort of kindly, cuddly, race relations bill. Ted Heath says to his colleagues, okay, well, we're not racists. So we're not going to, we don't want to come out madly against this. What we'll do is we will quibble about the details of it because that's what oppositions do,
但我们会同意原则。所有其他保守党人都说，太棒了。他们在1968年复活节前开了最后一次会议。他们说，太棒了，这真是个好计划。祝复活节快乐。休息后再见。鲍威尔坐在那次会议上。他是影子国防发言人。
but we'll agree with the principle. And all the other Tories say, brilliant. They have a last meeting before Easter, 1968. They said, brilliant, what a great plan that is. Have a great Easter. See you after the break. And Powell sits in that meeting. He's the shadow defence spokesman.
他坐在那里怒火中烧，因为他认为我们应该在这个问题上与工党斗争。他不相信种族关系法案。他说现在是开始鼓励人们回家的时候了。应该，这是我们表明立场的机会。所以这就是演讲的背景。他于4月20日前往伯明翰，前往米德兰酒店向当地保守党活动人士发表讲话。他知道这会引起极大的争议。他事先对《伍尔弗汉普顿快报与星报》的编辑说，演讲会，我引用，“像火箭一样嘶嘶作响，但虽然所有火箭都会坠落到地球，但这枚火箭会留在空中。”而且他实际上已经
He sits there steaming with rage because he thinks we should be fighting labour on this issue. He doesn't believe in a race relations bill. And he says it's time to start encouraging people to go home. should, this is our chance to make a stand. So this is the context for the speech. He goes to Birmingham on the 20th of April, to the Midland Hotel to speak to local conservative activists. He knows this is going to be really controversial. He said to the editor of the Wolverhampton Express and Star beforehand, the speech would, and they quote, fizz like a rocket, but whereas all rockets fall to earth, this one is going to stay up. And he's actually sent
把演讲稿寄给了媒体。这就是原因。ATV，当地的电视公司，派了一个电视摄制组去拍摄片段，你可以在网上看到。那么让我们进入演讲。他以你读到的那个故事开始，汤姆。一位工人阶级选民写信给他，他说他想离开英国，因为，我引用，“15或20年后，黑人将对白人拥有支配权。”说出这样的话是多么令人难以置信的沉重。支配权，你知道，那是你选择用来开场的形象？而且再次，让人想起美国南方。没错。鲍威尔随后说出了你读到的那一行，“我已经能听到咒骂的合唱了。我怎么敢通过重复这样的谈话来挑起事端？”答案是我没有权利不这样做。现在，你可以对此吹毛求疵，我想，因为正如你所说，汤姆，你知道，埃德蒙·伯克的著名论点，你知道，每次议员收到一封疯狂的信，他们不必在下议院读出来。我的意思是，如果他们那样做，他们就永远停不下来了。总之，鲍威尔说了这一点，我想你做那段介绍性阅读时是以此结束的。这是英国一千年历史上前所未有的转变。他继续说，到2000年，这个国家可能有700万移民子女，占总人口的十分之一。现在，在当时，演讲的每一位批评者都说，这是为了夸大数字而进行的令人不齿的恐吓。我必须说他完全正确。当你查看2001年的人口普查时，英国有700万人是非白人，占总人口的11%。我的意思是，在他的演讲中，他说这是登记总署发言人给议会的官方数字。所以他实际上是在引用官方数字。但人们会说，哦，不，不，那不可能是对的。那根本不对。他的语气随后变得强硬。
out copies of the speech to the media. And that is why. ATV, the local television company, have sent a TV crew to film extracts, which you can see online. So let's get into the speech. He begins with the story that you read, Tom. A working class constituent has written to him, he says he wants to get out of Britain because, and I quote, in 15 or 20 years time, the black man will have the whip hand over the white man. What an unbelievably loaded thing to say. The whip hand, you know, that's the image that you choose to kick off with? And again, redolent of the American South. Exactly. Powell then says that line that you read, I can already hear the chorus of execration. How dare I stir up trouble by
他说，这些人是，我引用，“一个异类元素，我们应该鼓励他们回家。”然后是一句非常著名的话，“神欲使其灭亡，必先使其疯狂。”我们一定是疯了，作为一个国家，竟然允许每年流入约5万名家属。那是妻子、孩子、祖父母等等。这就像看着一个国家忙于堆积自己的火葬柴堆。现在，那种语言，我认为，绝对反映了他一直在观看美国骚乱的事实，不是吗？
repeating such a conversation? The answer is that I do not have the right not to do so. Now, you can quibble about that, I think, because as you said, Tom, you know, Edmund Burke's famous argument, you know, every time an MP gets a mad letter, they don't have to read it out in the House of Commons. I mean, if they did, they'd never stop. Anyway, Powell says this point, I think you ended with when you did that introductory reading. It's a transformation unprecedented in a thousand years of English history. He goes on to say by 2000, there could be seven million children of immigrants in this country, one-tenth of the whole population. Now, at the time, every critic of a speech said, this is disgraceful scaremongering to inflate the numbers in this
火葬柴堆，即将解体的感觉，所有这些。然后他转向种族关系法案。他说，我坚决反对这一点。普通人可以把房间租给他们喜欢的任何人，把房子卖给他们喜欢的任何人。如果他们想歧视，政府没有权利阻止他们。然后他继续说，你知道，这是一个很好的例子，他说，普通英国人现在是一个受迫害的少数群体。不满的政治，你知道，我们对那很熟悉。
way. I have to say he was dead right. When you look at the 2001 census, seven million people non-white in Britain, 11% of the entire population. I mean, in his speech, he says that that is the official figure given to Parliament by the spokesman of the Registair General's office. So he is actually quoting official figures with that. But people will like, oh, no, no, that can't be right. That's not right at all. His tone then gets harder.
现在是演讲中非常、非常、非常煽动性的部分。他读了一封信，他说，诺森伯兰郡的一位妇女写信给我，告诉我伍尔弗汉普顿的一位年长女房东，她是她街上剩下的唯一白人妇女。它已经被，我引用，“被移民接管了”。她开始害怕出门。窗户被打破了。她发现排泄物被塞进她的信箱。当她去商店时，她被孩子们跟着，迷人的、咧着嘴笑的黑人小孩。他们不会说英语，但他们知道一个词。种族主义者，他们高呼。当新的种族关系法案通过时，这个女人确信
He says, these people are, and I quote, an alien element, and we should be encouraging them to go home. Then a very famous line, those whom the gods wish to destroy, they first make mad. We must be mad. literally mad as a nation to be permitting the annual inflow of some 50,000 dependents. That's the wives and children and grandparents and whatnot. It is like watching a nation busily engaged and heaping up its own funeral pyre. Now, that sort of language, I think, definitely reflects the fact that he's been watching the riots in America, no?
她会坐牢。我开始怀疑，她错了吗？现在，这些不是伊诺克·鲍威尔的话。他当然是在读一封信。现在，听众可以自己决定，我想，他读这封信是否正确。是的，我的意思是，只是说，一方面，在他的演讲中，他声称这是我收到的关于这个主题的数百封信中的一封。所以他说他是挑选出来的。另一方面，我的意思是，正如你所说，嗯，煽动性。但是，我的意思是，我会说，邪恶。
The funeral pyre, the sense of impending dissolution, all of this. Then he turns to the race relations bill. He says, I'm dead against this. Ordinary people can rent their rooms, sell their houses to whoever they like. If they want to discriminate, it's not the government's right to stop them. And then he goes on to say, you know, this is a good example, he says, of how ordinary English people are now a persecuted minority. The politics of grievance, you know, we're very familiar with that.
你知道，我慎重地使用了这个词，因为鲍威尔是一个沉浸在圣经预言中的人。他知道文字、故事和轶事的力量。我认为以他自己的道德标准来评判他，这些话是邪恶的。好吧，你知道吗？让我们深入了解一下这个故事。老妇人的想法，她坐在被移民包围的房子里，人们把排泄物塞进她的信箱，孩子们在街上对她高呼。鲍威尔的一些批评者说
Now the really, really, really inflammatory bit of the speech. He reads out a letter, he says, A woman in Northumberland has written to me telling me about an elderly landlady in Wolverhampton, She's the only white woman left in her street. It has been, and I quote, taken over by immigrants. She is becoming afraid to go out. Windows are broken. She finds excreter pushed through her letterbox. When she goes to the shops, she's followed by children, charming, wide, grinning piccaninnies. They cannot speak English, but one word they know. Racialist, they chant. When the new race relations bill is passed, this woman is convinced
这是极右翼形象的教科书，这是国民阵线和英国那些极右翼种族主义团体散布的民间故事。他的辩护者说不，这个女人是一个真实的人，
she will go to prison. And is she so wrong, I begin to wonder. Now, these are not Enoch Powell's words. He is reading a letter, of course. Now, listeners can decide for themselves, I think, whether or not he was right to read the letter. Yeah, I mean, just to say, on the one hand, in his speech, he claims that it's one of hundreds upon hundreds of letters I received on the subject. So he says he's picking it out. On the other, I mean, it is, as you say, well, inflammatory. But, I mean, I would go so far as to say, wicked.
他完全有权读这个故事，这是一个可怕的故事。当时，报纸付出了巨大的努力试图找出这个女人是否存在，他们断定没有这样的女人。现在，在2007年，坦率地说，这似乎是很久以后了。但总之，BBC做了他们自己的调查，一个广播纪录片，他们找到了一个叫德鲁西拉·科特里尔的女人，住在伍尔弗汉普顿的布莱顿广场，当时61岁。
You know, and I use the word advisedly because Powell is a man steeped in biblical prophecy. He knows the value of words and of stories and of anecdotes. And I think that judging him by his own moral standards, those are wicked things to say. Well, do you know what? Let's just go into this story a little bit. The idea of the old woman, and she's sitting in her house surrounded by immigrants, and people are pushing excreter through her letterbox, and kids are chanting at her in the street. some of Powell's critics said
然而，正如你所说，嗯，再次，我认为这取决于听众。读出一个你知道，嗯，你知道，也许是例外或误导性的故事，或者注定会激发出你的一些听众最坏的一面，这样做对吗？让我们看看他接下来要说什么，因为这是著名的高潮，不是吗？“像罗马人一样，我似乎看到台伯河泛着大量的血。”那个我们在大西洋彼岸惊恐地注视着的悲剧性和棘手的现象，
this is a textbook far right image this is the kind of folk tale that is being spread by the kind of national front and by the little far right racist groups in Britain his defenders said no the woman is a real person
但它与国家本身的历史和存在交织在一起，正因我们自己的意志和我们自己的忽视而降临到我们这里。他本质上是在警告一场种族战争。是的，没错。这就是当时人们使用的短语。我认为他使用的语言是为了使这种情况更有可能发生，而不是减少它。好吧，这就是《泰晤士报》周一社论所说的。一篇旨在煽动种族间仇恨的邪恶演讲。而这正是他的保守党同事所想的。所以这就是问题所在。他曾与这个叫伊恩·麦克劳德的人是好朋友，已经提到过他了。他最老的朋友之一。他们自
he's got every right to read this story it's a terrible story at the time the newspapers went to enormous efforts to try and find out if this woman existed and they decided that there was no such woman Now, in 2007, it seems a long time afterwards, frankly. But anyway, the BBC did their own investigation, a radio documentary, and they came up with a woman called Drusilla Cotterill, Brighton Place, Wolverhampton, age 61 at the time.
他们相识于保守党研究部以来一直是朋友。麦克劳德对他的同事说，那天晚上给他的同事打了电话，他对他们说，伊诺克疯了，讨厌黑人。希思那天晚上解雇了他的国防发言人。我认为鲍威尔可能知道他可能会被解雇，可能希望它发生，因为它会使他成为烈士，并且会，你知道，增加他对保守党基层的吸引力。而且很多人，包括右翼人士，包括鲍威尔的朋友，汤姆，完全同意你的观点。
However, as you say, well, again, I think it's up to the listener. Is it right to read out a story that you know, well, you know, is perhaps exceptional or misleading, or is bound to bring out the worst in some of your listeners. Let's look at what he then goes on to say, because this is the famous climax, isn't it? Like the Roman, I seem to see the River Tiber foaming with much blood. That tragic and intractable phenomenon which we watch with horror on the other side of the Atlantic,
当地报纸的编辑，那个他曾说“会像火箭一样嘶嘶作响”的人，克莱姆·琼斯，未来BBC政治记者尼克·琼斯的父亲，从80年代和90年代开始。克莱姆·琼斯曾是鲍威尔及其家人的密友，他在这次演讲后基本上断绝了他们的关系，因为像你一样，他说，你完全知道你在做什么。选择那种语言和那些例子是如此具有煽动性。你知道，这是极其不负责任的。但他是一位报纸编辑。他问他的读者，寄进来，你知道，告诉我们你的想法。他说，我们收到了35000张支持鲍威尔的明信片。我们几乎没有收到反对的。全国的情况也是一样。四分之三的人说他们支持他。邮局有
but which there is interwoven with the history and existence of the states itself, is coming upon us here by our own volition and our own neglect. He is warning essentially of a kind of race war. Yes, exactly. That's the phrase that people used at the time. The language that he is using is calculated to make that likelier not to diminish it, I would say. Well, that's what the Times editorial said on the Monday. An evil speech calculated to inflame hatred between the races. And that is what his conservative colleagues thought. So this is the thing. He'd been great pals with this guy Ian McLeod mentioned him already. One of his oldest friends. They've been friends since
但这种与国家本身的历史和存在交织在一起的东西，正因我们自己的意愿和疏忽而降临到我们身上。他本质上是在警告一场种族战争。是的，完全正确。这就是当时人们使用的措辞。我会说，他所使用的语言旨在使其更有可能发生，而不是减少这种可能性。嗯，这就是《泰晤士报》周一社论所说的。一场旨在煽动种族间仇恨的邪恶演讲。而这正是他保守党同事们的想法。所以这就是问题所在。他曾与伊恩·麦克劳德（Ian McLeod）是好朋友，我已经提到过他了。他最老的朋友之一。他们自相识以来就是朋友
they'd met in the Conservative Research Department. McLeod said to his colleague, rang his colleagues up that night, and he said to them, Enoch has gone mad and hates the blacks. And Heath sacked him as defense spokesman that evening. I think Powell probably knew that he might get sacked, possibly wanted it to happen because it would make him a martyr and would, you know, increase his appeal to the Tory grassroots. And an awful lot of people, including people on the right, including people who've been Powell's friends, Tom, completely agreed with you.
他们在保守党研究部相遇。麦克劳德那天晚上给他的同事们打了电话，他说，伊诺克疯了，他仇视黑人。希思当晚就解除了他的国防发言人职务。我认为鲍威尔可能知道他可能会被解雇，甚至可能希望这种情况发生，因为这会使他成为烈士，并会增加他对保守党基层选民的吸引力。汤姆，很多人，包括右翼人士，包括鲍威尔的朋友，都完全同意你的观点。
you. The editor of the local paper, the guy he had said, it will fizz like a rocket, Clem Jones, the father of the future BBC political correspondent, Nick Jones, from the sort of 80s and 90s. Clem Jones had been a really close friend of Powell and his family, and he basically broke off their relationship after this speech because, like you, he said, you knew exactly what you were doing. It is so inflammatory to choose that language and those examples. You know, it's utterly irresponsible. But he was a newspaper editor. He asked his readers, send in, you know, tell us what you think. He said, we got 35,000 postcards in favour of power. We got none, virtually none against. Same story nationally. Three out of four people said they supported him. The post office had
你。当地报纸的编辑，那个曾对他说“这会像火箭一样升空”的人，克莱姆·琼斯（Clem Jones），也就是80年代和90年代BBC未来政治记者尼克·琼斯（Nick Jones）的父亲。克莱姆·琼斯曾是鲍威尔及其家人的挚友，但在这次演讲后，他基本上与鲍威尔断绝了关系，因为像你一样，他说，你非常清楚自己在做什么。选择那种语言和那些例子是如此具有煽动性。你知道，这极其不负责任。但他是一位报纸编辑。他要求读者写信告诉他他们的想法。他说，我们收到了35000张支持鲍威尔的明信片。我们几乎没有收到反对的。全国的情况也是如此。四分之三的人表示支持他。邮局当时
to give him a special van because he had so many letters of support. Tens and tens of thousands of letters. And most famously, hundreds of dockers from the East End marched on Westminster, with placards, don't knock Enoch, or indeed, back Britain, not black Britain. And what they were calling for was for Heath to bring him back to the shadow cabinet, a shadow defence spokesman. Can you imagine any other point in British history where dockers have given a damn about who was in the shadow cabinet? They're not even the real cabinet.
给他一辆特别的货车，因为他收到了太多的支持信。成千上万封信。最著名的是，数百名来自东区的码头工人游行前往威斯敏斯特，举着标语，写着“别抨击伊诺克”，或者“支持英国，而不是黑人英国”。他们呼吁希思让他回到影子内阁，担任影子国防发言人。你能想象英国历史上还有哪个时刻，码头工人会关心谁在影子内阁里吗？他们甚至不是真正的内阁成员。
I mean, it's mind-boggling. And we can talk in a few minutes about where this leads politically. So Powell himself, this makes him, of course, a pariah to liberals, but this really does make him the tribune of the plebs to people who agree with him. Polls again and again in the next few years find that he's one of the most admired politicians, if not the most admired politician in the country. There's a brilliant book, actually, of people who are interested in kind of grassroots opinion by a journalist called Jeremy Seabrook, called City Close Up,
我的意思是，这太令人难以置信了。我们几分钟后可以谈谈这在政治上会导致什么。所以鲍威尔本人，这当然使他成为自由派眼中的贱民，但这确实使他成为那些同意他观点的人心目中的平民代言人。在接下来的几年里，民意调查一次又一次地显示，他是该国最受钦佩的政治家之一，如果不是最受钦佩的话。事实上，有一本关于那些对基层舆论感兴趣的人的精彩书籍，是由一位名叫杰里米·西布鲁克的记者写的，书名叫《城市特写》，
and he went to Blackburn at the end of the 60s, early 70s, and interviewed loads of people, hung around working men's clubs and stuff. And these are people who don't follow Westminster politics. You know, very, very sort of small, oh, ordinary people. And Powell's name came up again and again. He's the finest man in the country. He should be prime minister.
他在60年代末、70年代初去了布莱克本，采访了很多人，在工人俱乐部等地闲逛。这些人并不关注威斯敏斯特的政治。你知道，非常非常普通的普通人。鲍威尔的名字被一次又一次地提起。他是这个国家最优秀的人。他应该成为首相。
He speaks the mind of all the white, well, three quarters of the white people in this country. You know, you see this again and again. He wins polls. He won a BBC poll twice in the 1970s, man of the year. I mean, this is BBC listeners. And he is a wintry and ascetic lover of dead languages. But in a weird way, I think that kind of contributes to the appeal, right? That this guy has descended from an ivory tower on top of Mount Olympus to come down to speak for the masses.
他说出了这个国家所有白人，嗯，四分之三白人的心声。你知道，你一次又一次地看到这一点。他赢得了民意调查。他在20世纪70年代两次赢得BBC的年度人物民意调查。我的意思是，这是BBC的听众。他是一个冷峻而苦行的死语言爱好者。但以一种奇怪的方式，我认为这反而增加了他的吸引力，对吧？这个家伙从奥林匹斯山顶的象牙塔走下来，为大众说话。
The flip side is he destroys his political career forever with this speech. So a lot of MPs shun him, actually not his mate Michael Foote in particular in the future leader of the Labour Party, who actually makes a point after the speech of going. and shaking his hand, you know, and being friendly to him, showing other MPs that he still is going to be Enoch's friend. Isn't that interesting? Anyway, two things that actually get lost to me in the talk about immigration. We mentioned at the beginning.
另一方面，他因为这次演讲永远毁掉了自己的政治生涯。所以很多议员避开他，实际上他未来的工党领袖迈克尔·富特并不是这样，他在演讲后特意去和他握手，你知道，对他很友好，向其他议员表明他仍然会是伊诺克的朋友。这难道不有趣吗？总之，在关于移民的讨论中，有两件事实际上被我忽略了。我们在开头提到了。
In the next few years, Powell establishes what becomes the sort of economic gospel of Thatcherism, criticizing Ted Heath, for example, in the early 70s for spending too much and whatnot. And then when Britain joins Europe in 1973, Powell is the chief critic. He's the guy who basically invents Euroscepticism. So, you know, as his biographer, Simon Heffer says, if you judge a politician by his intellectual legacy, then he kind of stands alone in his generation because he basically bequeaths two things that are massively important in changing Britain. But he does it from the wilderness. Indeed, he ends up becoming an Ulster Unionist MP, not a Tory MP.
在接下来的几年里，鲍威尔确立了后来成为撒切尔主义经济福音的东西，例如在70年代初批评泰德·希思支出过多等等。然后当英国在1973年加入欧洲时，鲍威尔是主要的批评者。他基本上是发明了欧洲怀疑论的人。所以，正如他的传记作者西蒙·赫弗所说，如果你通过政治家的知识遗产来评判他，那么他在他那一代人中是独一无二的，因为他基本上留下了两件对改变英国至关重要的东西。但他是在荒野中完成这一切的。事实上，他最终成为了一名阿尔斯特统一党议员，而不是保守党议员。
And I suppose this idea of a politician being massively influential on British history, despite not holding high office or becoming prime minister or whatever, that is also what a lot of people say about Nigel Farage. And I suppose the contrast with Farage and Powell is precisely that Powell is a massive intellectual, as well as someone who is capable of serving as a lightning rod for opinions that otherwise are not being articulated. Yeah, I think that's true. I think that's true. Now, I think some people listening to this would say, look, it's very unfair to just do this all about immigration. You're distorting Powell's record because he has so much more to offer. I have to say I don't think it's unfair because the point about the rivers of blood speech is not that it's just one speech. Power returns to the issue again and again in the next few years. A good example, really good example, 1972, Idi Amin kicked out Ugandan Asians from Uganda. And Powell led to the campaign to stop them. them coming to Britain. And he said, many white people in Britain feel as if they are tied to a stake in the face of an advancing tide. You know, the advancing tide image, really. That's the one you go for.
我想，尽管没有担任高级职务或成为首相，但一位政治家对英国历史产生巨大影响的这种想法，也是很多人对奈杰尔·法拉奇的评价。我想法拉奇和鲍威尔之间的对比恰恰在于，鲍威尔是一位伟大的知识分子，同时也是一个能够充当避雷针的人，表达那些原本没有被表达出来的观点。是的，我认为这是真的。我认为这是真的。现在，我想听这个节目的一些人会说，看，把这一切都归咎于移民是非常不公平的。你在歪曲鲍威尔的记录，因为他还有更多的东西可以提供。我必须说，我不认为这不公平，因为关于“血河”演讲的重点不是它只是一个演讲。鲍威尔在接下来的几年里一次又一次地回到这个问题上。一个很好的例子，非常好的例子，1972年，伊迪·阿明将乌干达亚裔赶出了乌干达。鲍威尔领导了阻止他们来到英国的运动。他说，英国的许多白人感觉就像在不断上涨的潮水面前被绑在木桩上一样。你知道，不断上涨的潮水的形象，真的。这就是你选择的那个。
Now, we're talking about 27,000 people, middle class people by and large, who became one of the most successful of all immigrant communities. So the Tory politician, Priti Patel, her parents were Ugandan Asians. And actually, some listeners, even listeners sympathetic to people, Powell, I would say, might well ask themselves, was he right to say that none of these people should have been allowed in? Because actually the Ugandan Asian community proved enormously successful, assimilated very smoothly. And why did he, you know, he talks about the white people frightened and powerless. But he doesn't really talk about the Ugandan Asians who've been kicked
现在，我们谈论的是27000人，大体上是中产阶级，他们成为了最成功的移民群体之一。所以保守党政治家普里蒂·帕特尔，她的父母就是乌干达亚裔。实际上，一些听众，甚至是同情鲍威尔的听众，我想说，很可能会问自己，他当时说这些人都不应该被允许进入是对的吗？因为实际上乌干达亚裔社区证明是非常成功的，非常顺利地融入了社会。为什么他，你知道，他谈到白人感到恐惧和无力。但他并没有真正谈论那些被赶出自己国家、无处可去、感到恐惧和无力的乌干达亚裔难民。
out of their country, have nowhere to go of frightened and powerless refugees. I think that would be one of my main criticisms of Powell. That's sort of the lack of empathy, if you like. Anyway, he keeps beating this drum throughout the 1970s. I mean, he uses some pretty striking language. When he looks into the eyes of Asia, the Englishman comes face to face with those who would dispute with him the possession of his native land. Again, you could hardly choose a more emotive and incendiary image, right?
我认为这将是我对鲍威尔的主要批评之一。如果可以的话，那就是缺乏同理心。总之，他在整个70年代一直在敲打这个鼓。我的意思是，他使用了一些非常引人注目的语言。当他注视着亚洲的眼睛时，英国人与那些将与他争夺这片土地所有权的人面对面。同样，你几乎找不到比这更感性和煽动性的形象了，对吧？
struggling for possession of land with these people? Again, I mean, he presumably he's saying this because he fears, well, rivers of blood, but the language he is using is making that more likely, isn't it? I mean, it's... Yeah, I mean, I would say so, actually. To give, put my cards on the table, I always slightly sigh and roll my eyes when people just say in a very sort of blanket, condemnatory way, oh, in a pal, terrible racist, end of story.
与这些人争夺土地所有权？再说一次，我的意思是，他大概说这话是因为他害怕，嗯，血河，但他使用的语言正在使这种情况更有可能发生，不是吗？我的意思是，它是……是的，我的意思是，我确实会这么说。为了表明我的立场，每当人们以一种非常笼统、谴责的方式说，哦，伊诺克·鲍威尔，可怕的种族主义者，故事结束了，我总是会稍微叹气并翻个白眼。
Because I always think, no, it's never the end of the story. There's always more nuanced and there's always an interesting history behind this. But when you read those words, I think it's very, very hard to defend these choices. And actually, to go to this question of, is Enoch Powell a racist? The word racist is so loaded and so complicated. It depends what you mean, of course. Its meaning has evolved quite drastically over the past decades. It's become a far more capacious, hasn't it?
因为我总是认为，不，这绝不是故事的结局。总有更细微的差别，背后总有一段有趣的历史。但当你读到这些话时，我认为很难为这些选择辩护。实际上，回到这个问题，伊诺克·鲍威尔是种族主义者吗？“种族主义者”这个词太沉重、太复杂了。当然，这取决于你的意思。在过去的几十年里，它的含义已经发生了巨大的演变。它变得更加宽泛了，不是吗？
Yeah, it's capacious. Does he hate all foreigners? Clearly, no, he was hardly. going to be teaching himself all these languages if he hates foreigners. Is he prejudiced against individual people based on their skin colour? There's actually no evidence of that. He seems to have treated his foreign-born constituents exactly the same as his native-born constituents.
是的，它很宽泛。他讨厌所有的外国人吗？显然不是，如果他讨厌外国人，他就不太可能自学所有这些语言。他是否基于肤色对个人有偏见？实际上没有证据表明这一点。他似乎对待外国出生的选民与对待本土出生的选民完全一样。
So again, and you'll be able to tell that the focus of my research for this episode has very much been Desert Island Discs. But Sue Lawley puts that question to him, and he says, no, he'd feel just the same about a load of French people coming over. So maybe that's expressive of his views on the Norman conquest, I don't know. Does he believe in racial hierarchy? He says very clearly, no, I do not. I do not believe that one race is superior to another.
所以，你能够看出我这一集的研究重点非常集中在《荒岛唱片》上。但苏·劳利向他提出了这个问题，他说，不，如果有一群法国人过来，他也会有同样的感觉。所以也许这表达了他对诺曼征服的看法，我不知道。他相信种族等级制度吗？他非常清楚地说，不，我不相信。我不相信一个种族优于另一个种族。
Does he believe there are such things as races? Yes, he absolutely does. Racial difference is an undeniable truth. Now, here's something I would absolutely disagree with him about. He says, I think it is impossible that black and Asian people can become English. He says that they have no investment in England and its history. They can't be English. They'll never be English.
他相信有种族这种东西吗？是的，他绝对相信。种族差异是一个不可否认的事实。现在，这是我绝对不同意他的一点。他说，我认为黑人和亚裔不可能成为英国人。他说他们对英国及其历史没有投入。他们不可能是英国人。他们永远不会是英国人。
their children will not be English. They are, you would often use the words, an alien element. Now, in other words, he would say that Rishi Sunag, or the current conservative leader, Kemi Badenock, cannot be English. Now, listeners, I think, can decide for themselves whether they agree with him or whether they think that's racist. It's not for me to tell them what to think. I mean, I don't agree with him.
他们的孩子也不会是英国人。他们是，你经常会用“外来元素”这个词。现在，换句话说，他会说里希·苏纳克或现任保守党领袖凯米·巴德诺克不可能是英国人。现在，听众们，我想，可以自己决定他们是否同意他的观点，或者他们是否认为那是种族主义。我不应该告诉他们该怎么想。我的意思是，我不同意他的观点。
I think Kami Bidnok or Rishi Sunak, I think they are English. I mean, it's an interesting question. And there's another dimension to this that personally I find impossible to ignore. He always talked about the feelings of his white constituents, but almost never those of his black and Asian ones. And he never really seemed to consider the impact of his words. So there are lots of stories about incidents after his speech. Just one. There was a christening party in Wolverhampton, 10 days afterwards, so at the end of April, 1968, for a black family.
我认为凯米·巴德诺克或里希·苏纳克，我认为他们是英国人。我的意思是，这是一个有趣的问题。还有一个维度，我个人觉得无法忽视。他总是谈论他的白人选民的感受，但几乎从不谈论他的黑人和亚裔选民的感受。他似乎从未真正考虑过他言论的影响。所以有很多关于他演讲后发生的事件的故事。仅举一例。1968年4月底，也就是演讲10天后，在伍尔弗汉普顿有一个黑人家庭的洗礼派对。
and the christening party was attacked by white youths with knives who were chanting Enoch Powell's name. The grandfather was a guy called Wade Crooks and he had to be taken for treatment because he needed eight stitches after being slashed over his eye. And he said he'd lived in Wolverhampton since 1955, nothing like this has ever happened before. And there are lots of incidents like this.
洗礼派对遭到了挥舞着刀子的白人青年的袭击，他们高呼伊诺克·鲍威尔的名字。祖父是一个叫韦德·克鲁克斯的人，他不得不接受治疗，因为他在眼睛被割伤后需要缝八针。他说他自1955年以来一直住在伍尔弗汉普顿，以前从未发生过这样的事情。像这样的事件有很多。
Now on television, David Frost, big interview of the day, asked Enoch Powell to condemn these incidents. And Powell said, no. I'm not going to start condemning the behavior of people who are condemned by their own actions. It is not for a politician to be a preacher. I would say, is it so difficult really to condemn these actions? You know, clearly it's incumbent on you at this point if you have some responsibility to say, I would, if people are chanting your name, Tom, I mean, come on, would you not feel, of course you'd feel terrible about that. But it's interesting also that
现在在电视上，当天的重头采访大卫·弗罗斯特要求伊诺克·鲍威尔谴责这些事件。鲍威尔说，不。我不会开始谴责那些被自己的行为所谴责的人的行为。政治家不应该是传教士。我会说，谴责这些行为真的那么难吗？你知道，如果你有某种责任，此时此刻显然有义务说，如果人们高呼你的名字，汤姆，我的意思是，拜托，难道你不会感到，当然你会对此感到糟糕。但有趣的是，
essentially the implication of that is that a politician should not have a moral perspective and promoted. I mean, that's basically what being a preacher is. And he is, I mean, he does all the time. I mean, his speech about Kenya was an example of preaching. The reason he doesn't want to do it, it's so, it's obvious and it's so familiar. He doesn't want to condemn it because he doesn't want to give an inch to his critics. I think it's pride and stubbornness. And that, I would argue, leads him to take positions that would call. me concern if I was taking them, right? If I knew that people on the far right, gangs of skinheads were chanting my name as they attacked immigrants, if I knew, to quote a Times
本质上，这意味着政治家不应该有道德视角并加以推广。我的意思是，这基本上就是传教士所做的。而且他，我的意思是，他一直在这样做。我的意思是，他关于肯尼亚的演讲就是一个传教的例子。他不想这样做，原因很明显，也很熟悉。他不想谴责它，因为他不想向批评者让步。我认为这是骄傲和固执。而且我认为，这导致他采取了如果是我采取这些立场会让我担心的立场，对吧？如果我知道极右翼分子、光头党团伙在袭击移民时高呼我的名字，如果我知道，引用《泰晤士报》的一篇
editorial, that people had the impression that I hated black and Asian people, that they had a, they were right to be afraid of me, right? I would be really troubled by that. And I would be desperate to show people that I wasn't racist, you know, that I was a, I was a kindly person. I mean, even if I'm not a terribly kindly person, I'm definitely not a racist person. Anyway, I wouldn't want people to come to that conclusion, but Powell never seems to give their anxieties any thought. And I think that is a massive failure of empathy, personally. Anyway, what about his legacy? I think an obvious, unanticipated consequence of this speech in the furorre is that his exile, as it were, is so complete that it deters other politicians
社论的话，人们认为我讨厌黑人和亚裔，他们有理由害怕我，对吧？我会为此感到非常不安。我会拼命向人们证明我不是种族主义者，你知道，我是一个善良的人。我的意思是，即使我不是一个非常善良的人，我也绝对不是一个种族主义者。总之，我不想让人们得出那个结论，但鲍威尔似乎从未考虑过他们的焦虑。我个人认为，这是同理心的巨大缺失。总之，他的遗产是什么？我认为这次演讲和骚乱的一个明显的、未预料到的后果是，他的流放是如此彻底，以至于它阻止了其他政治家
from even mentioning immigration. So I think in the 70s and 80s, the potential for kind of populist anti-immigration politics was always there, but it's really remarkable how nobody exploits it. Margaret Thatcher, who in many ways is a kind of pal disciple, does it just once. In 1978, in the Ilford by-election, she gave an interview and she said, People are really rather afraid that this country might be rather swamped by people with a different culture. There's a massive furority, backlash among her senior colleagues. She never does it again.
甚至提到移民。所以我认为在70年代和80年代，民粹主义反移民政治的潜力一直存在，但没有人利用它，这真的很了不起。玛格丽特·撒切尔在很多方面是鲍威尔的信徒，她只做了一次。1978年，在伊尔福德补选中，她接受采访时说，人们确实非常担心这个国家可能会被不同文化的人淹没。她的高级同事们反应强烈，引发了巨大的骚乱。她再也没有这样做过。
That is surely the overwhelming impact of his speech. It completely contradicts what I assume was his aim, which was to get the issue of immigration on the political agenda. The way that he frames it and the language that he uses ensures that politicians view it as toxic. And they may be reluctant to talk about it out. of political self-interest, you know, they don't want to damage their own names or reputations. But I think it's much more likely that they, they are genuinely afraid of, of kind of pandering to the worst instincts in people. And the fact that it is remembered as
这无疑是他演讲的压倒性影响。它完全违背了我认为他的目标，即把移民问题提上政治议程。他构建问题的方式和他使用的语言确保了政治家们认为它是毒药。他们可能出于政治私利而不愿谈论它，你知道，他们不想损害自己的名声或声誉。但我认为更有可能的是，他们确实害怕迎合人们最坏的本能。而它被记住为
the Rivers of Blood speech, what Powell does is to give a very resonant phrase, which dramatizes, I think for politicians across the parties, for decades to come, it dramatizes what has been the great moral anxiety ever since the Second World War and the discovery of what had happened in Nazi Germany, the anxiety that distinctive ethnic or religious minorities will be targeted in pogroms or worse. And that is the great shadow that hangs over the whole of Europe, really, after the war. But what Powell does is to give a distinctively British and poetic formulation to what politicians are then anxious to avoid. And the corollary of that in turn is that when there are obviously genuine issues around cultural differences that arise,
“血河”演讲的事实是，鲍威尔提供了一个非常响亮的短语，我认为这让几十年来各党派的政治家们戏剧化了自第二次世界大战和发现纳粹德国发生的事情以来最大的道德焦虑，即独特的少数民族或宗教少数群体将成为大屠杀或更糟情况的目标。这就是战后笼罩整个欧洲的巨大阴影。但鲍威尔所做的是，为政治家们急于避免的事情提供了一种独特的英国式和诗意的表述。而反过来，其必然结果是，当出现明显的关于文化差异的真正问题时，
mainstream politicians are reluctant to engage with it. and to criticise them. Yeah, I think he's an example that people don't want to follow, right? I mean, so people, they just say, well, stay clear. Don't talk about this. I mean, the irony is, of course, it feels to me like we've talked about nothing else for about the last 15 years or so. But I'll tell you one thing, one thing that people don't often say about his speech,
主流政治家不愿参与其中并批评他们。是的，我认为他是一个人们不想效仿的例子，对吧？我的意思是，所以人们只是说，好吧，离远点。不要谈论这个。我的意思是，讽刺的是，当然，对我来说，我们过去15年左右似乎什么都没谈过。但我告诉你一件事，人们在谈论他的演讲时很少说的一件事，
that people talk about it in terms of, do you agree with it or not? Is he a racist or isn't he? I mean, one obvious point, it seems to me, is that he's just wrong, that he said he was convinced. convinced that there would be American style, you know, and we're talking about 150 cities in 1967, you know, dozens of deaths. He thinks there will be unending racial conflict because, and don't forget, he's talking about this, partly based on skin color. He's talking about, he's not talking about religious groups, he's talking about people
人们在谈论它时，是基于你是否同意它？他是种族主义者还是不是？我的意思是，在我看来，一个明显的观点是，他只是错了，他说他确信。确信会有美国式的，你知道，我们谈论的是1967年的150个城市，你知道，几十人死亡。他认为会有无休止的种族冲突，因为，别忘了，他谈论这个，部分是基于肤色。他谈论的不是宗教团体，他谈论的是来自
from the Caribbean. In other words, fellow Christians who just happened to be from Jamaica or Barbados or whatever and that they will fight with the indigenous people of England for possession of their native land and I would say that's clearly not happened Power has a long legacy right and these issues have never gone away and let's just end with one aspect in which I think power was ahead of the game I mean I think he really is a prophet the Guardian had a brilliant columnist in the late 60s called Peter Jenkins and he wrote a really good piece on this after the speech. He said Powell has discovered something that we have not seen in British politics for a long time. He says what Powell exploits is,
加勒比海的人。换句话说，只是碰巧来自牙买加或巴巴多斯等的基督徒同胞，他们将与英国的原住民争夺他们本土土地的所有权，我会说这显然没有发生。鲍威尔有很长的遗产，对吧？这些问题从未消失，让我们以我认为鲍威尔领先于时代的一个方面结束。我的意思是，我认为他确实是一位先知。《卫报》在60年代末有一位出色的专栏作家叫彼得·詹金斯，他在演讲后写了一篇非常好的文章。他说鲍威尔发现了一些我们在英国政治中很久没有看到的东西。他说鲍威尔利用的是，
and I quote, a sense that the politicians are conspiring against the people, that the country is led by men who have no idea about what interests or frightens the ordinary people in the back streets of Wolverhampton. And this is coming, I think, after a period in which politics has been quite decorous and deferential. And the populist element has been very much downplayed. But I think that's, you know, Powell's real legacy. It's a kind of politics that was completely unfamiliar in late 60s Britain that is very familiar today. It's the politics of identity. You know, what is it to be English or to be British? And it's so charged, the politics of grievance, of feeling yourself part of a persecuted group. And above all the politics of populism, the idea of the masses
我引用一下，“一种政治家正在密谋反对人民的感觉，这个国家由那些根本不知道伍尔弗汉普顿后街普通人关心什么或害怕什么的男人领导。”我认为，这发生在一个政治一直相当得体和顺从的时期之后。民粹主义因素在很大程度上被淡化了。但我认为，你知道，这就是鲍威尔真正的遗产。这是一种在60年代末的英国完全陌生但在今天却非常熟悉的政治。这就是身份政治。你知道，什么是英国人或英国身份？它是如此充满活力，不满的政治，感觉自己是受迫害群体的一部分。最重要的是民粹主义的政治，大众
against the elite. And in that sense, Tom, I don't know if you agree. I think we are still living in Enol Powers Britain today. Well, thanks, Dominic. Yes. And this has been a very long episode, maybe the longest episode we've ever done. And I think that reflects both the inherent fascination of the topic and the sensitivities of the issues that it provokes. So thank you, everyone who has made it this far. Thank you, Dominic. And we will be back very soon with something completely different, namely Nelson's mistress, the scandalous life of Lady Hamilton. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
对抗精英的想法。从这个意义上说，汤姆，我不知道你是否同意。我认为我们今天仍然生活在伊诺克·鲍威尔的英国。好吧，谢谢你，多米尼克。是的。这是一集非常长的节目，也许是我们做过的最长的一集。我认为这反映了该主题固有的魅力以及它所引发的问题的敏感性。所以谢谢所有坚持到这里的人。谢谢你，多米尼克。我们将很快带着完全不同的东西回来，即纳尔逊的情妇，汉密尔顿夫人的丑闻生活。再见。再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。